Oh, look who we have here.
There we go.
>> How how how are you there? How are you
there?
>> Yeah, I'm good, man. How are you?
>> Oh, you've you've finally come for the
for the final boss, huh?
You want to ask me the questions, huh?
>> I came for the champ, man.
>> ask me the questions.
>> I came for the champ. I came for the
champ.
>> Go ahead and ask me the questions that
you want to ask.
>> Sure. But before we before we continue,
is it okay that I also want to ask you a
question?
>> I can't hear you very well there.
Uh-oh.
>> Testing testing. Are we okay? Testing
testing.
>> Yeah, raise it a little bit higher.
>> All right.
Let me uh
>> You look a bit nervous there, boy.
>> Man, you know big stage, man.
Big stage, you know what I'm saying?
>> stage and a big opportunity, huh?
>> It's the champ, man.
>> Oh, yes.
You wait till I get a good boy, Avery.
>> You're the people's you're the people's
champ, man. You've been start Yeah, I
don't know I don't know you was getting
your courage up or what. I don't know
what it was, but
I'm the giant killer.
>> Thank you.
>> So, is is it okay that I record this and
put it on my channel? Just want to get a
verbal confirmation. We're good?
>> Well, I mean, look, you can go live
right now. I mean, I haven't got any
issues with that myself.
>> Yeah, I'm recording.
Yeah, I'm recording right now. So, I'm
just making sure I can put
>> live. Go live so that your people can
see what's happening right now.
>> Oh, oh, they they will. So, I I just
want a verbal confirmation you're not
going to copyright strike me.
>> No, you're go you're going to go live
and it's absolutely fine.
>> Okay, cool. All right, awesome. All
right, so
>> We're going live simultaneously right
now, aren't we?
Just like the Father and the Son and the
Holy Spirit are simultaneously God, are
they?
>> This this is this is a recording. Just
like the Hafs and the Warsh and the Duri
are all simultaneously the Quran.
Yeah.
>> So, tell me now
>> Now, can I ask you a question?
>> This is a good way of doing it, Avery.
Okay?
>> Mhm.
>> A good way of doing it is you ask me a
question about Islam.
>> Yeah.
>> And then we can go back and forth on
that issue for some time. And then I ask
you a question about Christianity and we
can go back and forth on that issue for
it. So it's kind of equal.
>> Yeah.
>> Sounds about right, yeah?
>> Fair enough.
>> So I want you to do me the following
Avery.
I want you in front of the people that
are watching at home today. Everybody
watching at home, the Christians, the
Muslims, the Jews.
The Zionists, your friends, the
Zionists, everybody.
Want you to tell us
what your strongest I know you're
unqualified.
No, no, it's okay. You're not qualified,
you know, you don't have any formal
qualifications, you don't have any
degrees, you don't have any
certificates, you don't have any
diplomas.
I understand all that, but I give you
concession because I want you
>> Yeah.
>> to tell us your strongest argument
against Islam. Where all is Avery?
>> Ooh, nice. Thank you, I appreciate it,
man.
Yeah, yeah, man. I can't wait to give
it, you know, from someone who's
unqualified, no credentials, just a, you
know, young kid who just, you know, did
a lot of YouTube University. It says a
lot about that.
>> Just say Avery, let's get there.
>> I I am, man. I am. You don't got to set
it up.
>> Let's cut to the chase and give US THE
STRONGEST ARGUMENT, YOU BOY. I GOT TO
set it up. I got to set it up. I got to
set it.
Got to set it up, you know, it it it it
says a lot for someone who's unqualified
to do what I've done to the Dawah Squad
and now you're just laughing at me.
>> on with it, mate. Get on with it, mate.
>> So so what I'm going to say is Muhammad
hijab is that the strongest one of the
strongest, I wouldn't even say it's the,
but one of the strongest arguments that
I would like to use obviously would be
the Islamic dilemma that you said is a
easy easily
refuted and disregarded argument.
>> Sure.
>> love
to challenge you.
>> we start, that's your strongest
argument.
>> One of.
>> This is the way to undo Islam. The way
to undo Islam is the Islamic dilemma.
You've been in this apologetics thing
for a very long time. You believe this
is the strongest argument. You believe
that.
>> It's it's one of. I I believe the
strongest argument would
>> Okay, but what is the strongest one?
>> Muhammad's moral character.
>> No, don't
>> lose the confidence already. Come on,
what's the strongest argument? Let's go
for number one because we need to go
down.
>> I want to use this. I want to use the
Islamic dilemma. Can we stop wasting
time and talk about it?
>> Well, you can. That's your strongest
argument, right?
>> mashallah. Let's do it.
>> Okay, go ahead and make your argument.
>> All right, thank you. So, I'm going to
argue that from the Quran standpoint, it
points to the previous scriptures as
being authoritative over the Quran,
meaning it's the standard of truth over
the Quran, okay? And I'm going to use a
few verses. I'll we can deal with one at
a time.
My one of my favorite verses to use
would be chapter 10 verse 94.
>> Yes.
>> Okay?
And so this is what it says. It says,
"If you are in doubt" this is Allah
speaking to Muhammad, "If you are in
doubt about that which we have revealed
to you,
then go and ask those who have been
reading the scripture before you. Truly
the truth has come to you from your
Lord, so be not of those who doubt."
>> For sure.
>> So
let me ask you this, Avery. Have you
seen any of the exegesis on this?
Because it says, "If you're in doubt"
I'm sure you're aware. I know you're not
qualified, but you understand that a
conditional if is a conditional.
If you are in doubt, that's the Arabic
wording. If in kuntum fi shakin, if you
are in doubt. If you look at the
exegesis, they say he wasn't in doubt
and he never asked. So it's irrelevant.
Next one, please.
>> Okay, so notice since I'm unqualified,
it's it's a shame I got to teach you the
argument. Um I never
>> I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I
>> I got you a job. Please let me get it
out.
>> You hold on. Hold on. Hold on. You
>> I can't even get it out, ladies and
gentlemen.
>> You said one at a time. You said one at
a time. 10 94
>> trying to respond to what you said.
>> Surah Yunus, chapter number 10, verse
number 94.
>> Can I respond to what you said?
>> Wait. What are you are you are you are
you are you interrupting me or
>> You You cut me off and now you're saying
I'm interrupting you. You cut me off.
>> no, no, no, we're dealing with one at a
time, Avery.
>> I know. So you
made a statement about him not doubting.
Let me respond to that.
>> If you are in any doubt,
the ones who were given the book before.
>> So, you have
So, no, no. So, now the exegesis say
They say this is rhetorical. If
conditional, you're in doubt, then ask.
>> he supposed to do?
>> Then they say he never was in doubt
because the prophet was never in doubt.
And he never asked. He never asked in
this capacity. That's it. It's It's It's
Put that to the side.
>> Okay.
>> No problem.
>> So, thank you. I appreciate that. You
That was a waste of time because that's
not my argument. My argument isn't that
Muhammad was in doubt. Notice you're
cutting me off again.
This is the second time. Notice, if
you're not afraid of the argument, I'm
unqualified. Remember, I'm unqualified.
>> Second second verse, please.
>> I'm unqualified, ladies and gentlemen.
>> Just so, ladies and gentlemen,
>> that Muhammad was in doubt. My My
argument is not that Muhammad was in
doubt. My argument is what Allah tells
him to do if he does doubt. Now, just to
get this
just to get this under clarity, would
you agree that doubt means to be
uncertain of the truth?
>> Yeah. That's That's a good definition.
>> So, if Muhammad, conditional, granted,
that's what the verse says, if he's
uncertain about the truth of the Quran,
what is he told to do by Allah?
>> Give
Ask the people who have been given the
book before.
>> Awesome.
>> Yeah.
>> If he goes and asks, if he's uncertain
about the truth of what the Quran is
saying, and he goes and asks those
who've been reading the scripture before
him, that's supposed to help him gain
certainty of the truth if he sees that
the Quran is in line with what they
have, correct?
Is that Is that correct?
>> If you If you're in doubt, it says in
If you're in doubt.
I don't know why you're smoking and
grinning.
>> having a good time, man.
>> I know I know Hold on. Hold on. I know
why he's smoking and grinning cuz he's
not used to being in class because he's
never been in class.
>> Right.
>> There's nothing funny about this matter.
This is
>> None of this is helping anybody.
>> Look. Look. This is I know you're back
tooth apologist and I know that you're
you keep smoking and smiling. You think
that this is going to get you somewhere.
It's not going to get anywhere with
Muhammad hijab.
>> having a good time with you somewhere
with a couple of other guys here and
there.
>> Can you please get to the argument?
>> get you anywhere with Muhammad hijab
because the fact is this. The fact is
conditionals have been even proposed in
the Quran about Allah taking a son.
If Allah wanted to take a son, he could
have taken a So the conditional here uh
for the back tooth apologist you have
failed to give us anything of substance
at this point.
>> I'm just waiting on you to engage your
logical side.
>> you're presenting the strongest argument
against Islam. So please give us the
strongest argument. Go on.
>> All right, awesome. Thank you. So all of
that slander and all that That doesn't
work here, not with me. You're going to
have to actually deal with the argument.
So again, I'll ask the same question I
just asked. You didn't answer the
question. So here's the question again,
Muhammad hijab. So if Muhammad is
uncertain about the truth of the Quran
in in this scenario
and that then he's supposed to go ahead
when he asked the people the book,
right? He read the scripture before him.
Let me Let me land it.
I got you. So when he when he when he
does that if the Quran is in line with
what they have, then he'll be certain of
the truth about what the Quran is
saying, right? If he doubted it.
See look, this is the problem, okay? The
problem is when you haven't got a high
school diploma
>> Yeah.
>> and you're trying to use logic to answer
knowing anything
No no no this is the the fact is this.
You don't know what you're talking
about. Nowhere does it
Hold on. Hold on. Nowhere does it say.
You've added and you've added an I said
Jesus. You've added your own
superimposition
>> add anything. I just read it.
>> onto the Quranic text. Nowhere does it
say if the Quran
is if if you're in doubt then go and
then it can be corrected by the people
of the Where does it say that? Where
does it say that? Is there a hadith that
says that?
Do you know about
>> I'll show you again. So, when it says
that if you are in doubt, meaning what
you already agreed to means to be
uncertain of the truth of what the Quran
is saying,
>> Okay.
>> what he can do to get certainty of the
truth of what the Quran is saying is
asking the people who read the scripture
beforehand.
>> It doesn't say any of that. It says
>> Oh, it doesn't You You conceded that
earlier.
>> No, no, no. You just read the verse as
it is.
>> Mhm.
>> ask the people before you. That's it.
That's what it says.
But the question is The question is
Where's the argument here? So what? So
what? What's your argument? Is this
meant to undo Islam? I don't see any
threat. Where's the argument?
>> I got you. So So So again, so do you
agree with the verse that in the case in
the scenario that Muhammad doubts what
the Quran is saying, has uncertainty
about the what the Quran is saying, that
he can get certainty What he can get
certainty by asking the people who read
the scripture before, correct?
>> people. That's what it says. Yes, ask
the people, yes. Ask the people That's
what the verse says. Go ahead. Continue.
>> Who been doing what?
>> Say again?
>> Ask the people who what?
>> The ones who have been given the book.
>> There you go. So, in asking these people
who read the scripture before him, he
can then get certainty of whatever he
had doubted, correct?
What?
>> It's what the verse says, Hijab.
>> No, it doesn't say that. It says
It doesn't say
>> Why?
>> What do you call it? So you can get
certainty. It doesn't say any of what
you're saying. The question Where's your
argument? I'm trying to I'm I'm still
finding
I'm trying to find your argument.
>> Well, the argument's there. You You are
Okay. Hijab, let me ask you this.
Why is Allah Why What What is What is
this supposed to do for Muhammad if he's
uncertain about what the Quran is saying
by go and going to the people who read
the scripture before him? What does that
do for him in this situation? How does
that help?
>> this is your argument
Do you Is your argument the following?
Let's just be clear about this. Is your
argument that you believe
>> forward question, brother.
>> No, no. Is your argument that you
believe that
the Quran affirms the Torah and the
Injil, the Bible that you have in your
hands.
>> That's not my argument right now. My
argument
>> What's What is
>> I said it I got
I said it in the beginning. I said that
according to the Quran, the previous
scriptures are the authority or the
standard of truth over the Quran. And
here's my verse to prove it.
>> Who said that? Say it again. Who said
that? Where does it say that?
>> I said that. This is my argument.
>> Okay, so where does it say that in the
Quran?
>> I'm showing you. So again, with 10:94,
watch this. I'm I'm showing you. You got
to engage though. In 10:94,
it tells Muhammad if he is uncertain
about what the Quran is saying
>> Okay.
>> how he can gain certainty
>> It doesn't say that. He said if
>> Okay, so then then help me out.
>> If in the Quran
>> he saying that?
>> It says it doesn't say go and get gain
certainty.
It says just go and ask them.
>> I don't know. I'm just talking about his
doubts.
>> Yeah, I understand what you're saying.
But what I'm saying to you is the
exegesis have already explained that he
never had that doubt and he never asked.
So it's irrelevant.
>> I get the same type of rhetoric in my
life.
>> Do you have any other arguments because
this is getting boring for the
>> No, say that it's getting boring because
you can't even deal with the argument.
>> This is an extremely boring argument. He
doesn't have any way to
>> you should be able to pick it apart. If
it's
>> is What are you trying to say? Are you
trying to say that the Bible according
to us is preserved? Is that what you
>> What I'm saying is I'll say it again
very clearly.
>> that we believe the Bible is preserved?
Yes or no?
>> I got you. This is my third time saying
it. I got you. This will be my I got
you. This will be my third time saying
very clearly what I'm saying.
>> you the question. Do you believe that we
believe the Bible is preserved? Yes or
no?
>> I know you don't believe that. I know
you don't believe that. What My point
is, Suhaib, is that your beliefs go
against Islam. That's my point.
>> Say again. What's the What's the point?
>> Your beliefs go against the Quran. The
Quran here and I'll be very clear with
my point. The point that I'm proving and
I want you to focus on
is that the Quran points to the previous
scriptures as being the standard of
truth.
>> What
>> If you're disagreeing with that, I need
you to break this verse down for me and
show me how I'm wrong.
>> Okay. Okay. Yes. We believe in the
previous scriptures. Muslims believe in
the previous scriptures. Muslims also
believe that the scriptures that are in
our hands today from the Jews and the
Christians are corrupted. These two
things we believe at the same time. We
believe that there was original
scriptures that then got corrupted. Do
you understand this point or not?
>> I Trust me, I know your position. I
know.
>> Okay. So, if you understand this
position, what's the what's the point
here? Because if you believe that we
believe that it's corrupted, then you
understand that there are aspects of the
Bible now that you have in your hands
which could have their remnants back in
Torah and Injil, that they go back to
the actual Torah and Injil. And aspects
of the Bible which is stolen. For
example, the aspects that talk about Lot
having sex with his daughters or the
aspects that talk about, you know, for
example, Noah having the, you know, the
the the three sons and seeing them in
his nakedness and all these aspects
which or that Aaron committed shirk and
polytheism or you know, that
Jesus commanded according to 31:18 to
this, that, and the other. Take the
young girls for yourself. All of these
things are corrections the Quran came to
correct, you see.
So,
as I said to you before, the corrupt
Bible that we have today which there are
different versions of this. There's the
New International Version, there's the
Revised Standard Version, there's the
King James Version, there's whatever
version, different canons. 66 books, 73
books, whatever.
We don't believe that to be God's God's
word. We don't believe 13 books of Paul
are God's word. We don't believe in any
of that. So, where's the argument going
here? I don't see where the argument is
going.
>> Okay. So, I'll
I'll break it down. You know, remember
I'm unqualifed, so I got to dumb I only
talk in like dummy standards, okay?
According to the Quran,
the it points to the previous scriptures
as being the standard of truth, meaning
if Muhammad is uncertain about what the
Quran is relating, especially in regards
to the previous prophets, the previous
histories, their stories, and yada yada
yada. If Muhammad is in doubt, this is
conditional as you said, if he doubts
what the Quran is saying on these
matters,
then he can get clarity
on his doubts by going to the people who
read the scripture before him and asking
them about these things.
>> All right, so so what?
>> Right.
>> Okay, so it's saying that you can
if you're in doubt, you can go to the
people who the people of the book, the
people who have been given the scripture
before you. For example, some Jews, some
Christians. Those Jews like
for example, who the prophet went to a
person who's a monotheistic Christian at
the time, and he asked him for
questions. You know, this is a way to
reassure himself if he's in doubt or
whatever it may be. Yes, this is what
the Quran says. I want to understand
what the issue is here. Do you believe
so?
What's the argument?
>> So here's the here's the issue. So thank
you. So we got we got past this part. So
now, since we both now understand
that he can get clarity on whatever he
might have been doubting. Just if in
this in this case, he can get clarity he
can get clarity on the truth of what the
Quran is saying by going to the people
of the book and what they're reading.
This means that if Muhammad if what he's
receiving from the Quran
matches what they tell him from the
previous scriptures, then that will
clear up his doubts if he had any
regarding what the Quran's telling him,
correct?
>> Okay, let's go with it. Let's grant it.
Yeah,
next next. Yeah, go on.
>> Awesome. So that would clear up his
doubts if he saw that it lined up, okay?
So this means that the inverse is true,
that if he doubted and went to them
and they told him the opposite of what
the Quran was saying, then this would
actually verify his doubts and he
wouldn't have good reason to trust what
the Quran is saying regarding these
things, right?
>> Oh, this is so weak. You You have to
understand how uh what's it called
mafhum mukhalafa works. Mafhum mukhalafa
is uh is a principle
in usul al-fiqh and it's a principle in
usul al-tafsir, which is what is known
in diametrical opposition, okay? It's
not actually true that if I say, for
example, okay, don't if you drink this
hot tea,
then you will be uh
you'll be in a position where you
you have to go to the toilet, okay? It
doesn't mean that if I don't drink the
hot tea, that I will definitely not go
to the toilet, does it?
So, what you're saying is not
biconditional. It There's no reason for
you to think it's biconditional, that it
works in a symmetrical manner.
This is the weakness of Christian
apologetics nowadays. You can't even
think logically. The problem is you
can't even actually think properly. And
the And the issue is if you did
propositional logic course 101 in school
before you flunked out and did whatever
you've done. Yeah? If you did that, to
be honest with you, you I have a
buck-toothed apologist smiling again cuz
he's been caught out once again. The
point is if you understood how
biconditionality works, how if one thing
is happens, the other thing is then you
wouldn't come with these weak arguments,
okay? There is nothing in the Quran that
indicates or in the Hadith that
indicates that if the Prophet Muhammad
were to go to the Christian or the Jew,
and that if he were to correct them him,
he would have to now
go in line with what the Christian or
the Jew said. Because the Quran itself
edits the Bible.
It conscientiously corrects the Bible.
>> Oh.
>> For example,
>> Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Can I Can I talk
to you for a second?
>> in the Quran in chapter 50 of the Quran,
hold on. The Quran, the author is aware,
is he not? My question to you. The
author is aware, is he not? In chapter
50 of the Quran, where it says wa ma
massa hum min lughub, that no tiredness
touched him when he created the heavens
and the earth. He is aware of what what
was said in Genesis chapter 1 and also
in the book of Exodus where it says that
God rested and he refreshed nafash. So,
clearly it's correcting something in the
Bible. Correcting something in the hands
of the Christians and the Jews. It's
correcting it. And that's why the Quran
calls itself a Muhaimin. Muhaimin means
the corrector. It's the one that
corrects it. Wa Muhaiminan alaihi. It's
the corrector. You're saying to me
>> You're shotgunning points.
>> that the opposite is true, then that
must mean that you have no idea of the
Quran. You have no idea of tafsir. You
have no idea of what the scholars of
Islam said. You have no idea of Hadith.
And that's what happens when you put
forward when the Christian polemical
community put forward an individual who
doesn't know the Arabic language, who
doesn't know usul al-tafsir, who doesn't
know usul al-Quran, who doesn't know
anything, has never learned Islamic
studies in his life, and you put him
forward to discuss things with me. You
came here too early. You should have had
a couple of other journeymen. You should
have gone to the street and spoke to the
people. The Quran actually says the
opposite of what you're saying in
chapter 5.
>> bro?
>> The Quran says you lied upon the Quran
by saying that the Quran is indicating
that if if
>> How long you going to preach to me, man?
Let me Let's talk.
>> Muhammad, if the Prophet Muhammad were
to go to a Christian and the Christian
corrects him, then he must follow that.
The Quran says the opposite of that. The
Quran says that wa Muhaiminan alaihi,
which means that the Muhaimin
is a guardian,
is a is something which distinguishes
between truth and falsehood over the
over the over the previous
scriptures. You're telling me
>> now, bro? What's going on? Is this a
dialogue or not? You monologuing,
preaching.
>> You can ask your next question because
if this is your strongest argument, I
don't see how it is.
>> Okay, so you saying nah-uh, nah-uh is
not a a reputation of the argument.
>> Okay, go ahead and let me get to the
point. Get get to the point. What's your
next point?
>> I'm at the point. Let me start with your
example. Remember, you spoke for the
longest, so please give me the same
respect. You You said that if you drink
this hot tea, if you say if you drink
this hot tea, then you'll have to go to
the bathroom. Doesn't necessarily mean
that if you don't drink the hot tea that
you won't necessarily have to go to the
bathroom. That's a false equivalence
because in this in the example in your
phrase that you're saying that the the
tea is going to cause you to go to the
bathroom means that if you don't drink
the tea, then the tea is not going to
cause you
to go TO THE BATHROOM.
>> IT'S REALLY WHAT THEY'VE GOT NOW.
>> NONE OF THIS NONE of this is helping me.
The nervous laughter is not going to get
you out of this.
>> You're a stupid manual.
>> I got you. So So again
So So again So again, according to the
according to the passage This is what
you got This is what you need to help me
do, okay?
Okay, I got you. So this is what you
need to help me do.
>> What is that?
>> Since you conceded Since you conceded,
Muhammad Hijab Muhammad Hijab
Since you conceded
Since you conceded that Muhammad can get
clarity on the uncertainty of what the
Quran is saying by going to the previous
scriptures You did not Brother, we're
going to rewind your words and play it
back in front of you. Do you Do you need
to watch your clip back, dude? Stop
saying you never said this after you
said it.
Notice how you're interrupting me, man.
Why can't I speak?
You You got to let me get my argument
off, man.
You conceded it earlier and now you're
saying you never said that. We all saw
it, all of
This is absolutely embarrassing.
No No No
>> One second. One second. You said clarity
on what the Quran is saying. I never
once said
>> that's
>> I never once said any of that.
I never once said any of that. Now
you're lying.
>> lying up here. Remember, you're the
qualified guy and you have to take back
your words like this.
>> Okay. All right. I didn't say anything
about clarity of what the Quran is
saying. I didn't say clarity of what the
uncertain things the Quran is saying. I
didn't say anything about that. Okay?
>> Okay.
>> I've clearly stated to you the position.
The position is this. The position is
the Quoran says that it's a Muhaiman,
which means it's a guardian, and it
sieves out it filters it's a filter for
the truth of the Quoran.
>> it's a guardian. I thought it was a
filter.
>> Hold on. What Muhaiman and Ali? How do
you explain that, please?
>> Hold on. Hold on. Before you do the
Muslim shuffle, the hijab two-step,
first you need to do your argument. Hold
on. Hold on.
>> Muhaiman, if you know what the word
means.
>> Sure.
>> I just explained it.
>> The Quoran So, the it depends on your
interpretation. Because you have some
interpreters that interpreted that
Muhaiman, that it was Muhammad who was a
Muhaiman over the Quoran. And so, then
if you're going to be consistent, then
you're going to have to say Muhammad is
an authority or corruptor of his words
of Allah.
>> That's not what anyone says.
>> Which one is you going to hold?
>> Muhaiman and Ali, the Quoran is
Muhaiman. Wait, hold on. The The Quoran
is Al Muhaiman. It's called Al Muhaiman.
>> Would you like to see interpreters that
say otherwise? That say Muhammad is the
Muhaiman?
>> The Quoran the the verse is very clear
that the Quoran is the Muhaiman.
>> Not to everybody. To some of your
scholars, they say Muhammad is the
Muhaiman.
>> You see, look, you're having to lie now.
This is quite pathetic.
>> want me to show you? Can I share my
screen?
>> No, no, no. You don't need to share
anything. You're wasting You don't waste
What are you laughing at? It's the
Quoran's called Furqan.
>> I mean,
you don't like Muhaiman. You don't like
Muhaiman. Okay.
No, no, this is a joke.
>> What are you laughing at?
>> I I get I want to let I want to let you
know I get the same scoop said on my
everyday Monday
Monday, Wednesday, Friday stream. You're
no different than the everyday Muslim I
talk to.
>> What does Furqan mean? What does Furqan
mean?
>> Furqan means criterion.
>> Okay, so what does it mean?
What does it mean?
>> A
standard of truth. It tells you what's
right AND WHAT'S WRONG.
GUESS WHAT?
GUESS WHAT? GUESS WHAT?
THE QUORAN SAYS THE TORAH IS AL FURQAN.
>> ANY OTHER QUESTIONS?
>> TORAH IS AL-FURQAN. WHAT IS CHAPTER 21
verse 48? The Torah is al-furqan,
Muhammad.
>> hear what you're saying. I can't hear
it. Tell me something else.
>> I just said I just said that according
to your Quran, the Torah is al-furqan in
chapter 21 verse 48 and in chapter 2
verse 53, THE TORAH IS AL-FURQAN.
SO WHAT DO YOU GOT TO SAY ABOUT THAT?
THE TORAH IS A QURAN.
>> IS THE QURAN AL-FURQAN OR NOT? al-furqan
or not?
>> Yes, so is the Torah. So is the Torah.
Yes, so is the Torah.
Yes, so is the Torah, correct?
Wait, is is that correct? The Torah is
also al-furqan.
>> Wait, chapter 25, surah al-furqan, yeah?
It doesn't say the Torah is al-furqan.
It says Quran
>> It says I just said chapter 21 verse 48.
It says that we gave Moses and Aaron the
scripture and the criterion.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's true. That's
true.
>> Thank you, I know it's true.
>> Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold
on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on,
hold on. Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold
on, hold on, hold on. Can't both be
true.
>> What are you waking me up now?
>> What was given to Aaron and hold on,
hold on. So what was given to Aaron was
al-furqan, right?
>> Say that again.
>> What was given to Aaron and what was
given to Moses
>> I need to dress for the occasion. I'm
getting my is getting messy. Hold
on. Is what was given to
Are you okay? Is what's this guy doing?
He's a good get out of here. You want to
You want to throw the towel? You want to
throw the towel, boy? You want to throw
the towel?
Oh, come on.
Yeah, this is It works. It works.
Sit down, sit down, sit down.
He needs to do this. He needs to do
this, doesn't he?
>> He's getting agitated.
>> I need to I need to dress for the
occasion, man.
>> Okay.
Okay. All right, so now here's the
question. Here's a Here's the question,
too.
Are we Are we Are we done with your
logic? Are we done with your a dilemma?
>> Uh no, you haven't You haven't dealt
with it yet. You just said no. Answer
what you want to ask me now.
>> Okay, so so so continuing with the
argument cuz you said you never said
this. You said you never said this. So
I'm going to make you say it again.
>> What's your question? What what's your
question to me?
>> to give it to you.
I'm about to give it to you.
>> What what's your what's your question?
What's your question?
>> So,
when Allah tells Muhammad,
>> Yeah.
>> if you are in doubt
>> Mhm.
>> about what we have revealed to you, if
you're uncertain about the truth about
what we revealed to you,
>> I've asked you this question like four
or five times, right?
>> Because you keep flip-flopping like
flip-flopping on it.
>> you this question like four or five
times, haven't I?
>> you keep saying you said it and then you
didn't say it. The religion is yes, no,
yes, no.
>> You understand you understand you
understand that the Quran is referred to
as Muhaiman and Furqan, okay? You can't
get away from that.
>> Okay, so which means it's the criterion,
all right?
>> You said it's the criterion. You said
it's the criterion. You understand that
the Quran is a criterion over the
You understand you understand that when
Prophet Muhammad
saw Umar reading aspects of the Torah,
he told them that you have been given
something you don't need to read this.
Which is the Quran.
>> Say that again?
>> Are you
>> What's that again?
>> Can you say that one more time?
>> Yeah, please.
>> When when the Prophet Muhammad
saw Umar ibn al-Khattab reading aspects
of the Torah of the time which were
preserved, some aspects were preserved,
and he was reading it, he said that
you've been given something which
replaces this. So the the point is the
point is this, the Prophet
mentioned, yeah, in a Hadith, "Do not
believe them and do not believe them."
Do not believe them and do not believe
them.
>> Why?
>> Do not believe them and do not believe
them. Do you know this Hadith?
Do you know this Hadith?
In Bukhari.
>> Yes, so what what what did he say?
>> So so so so hold on. There are aspects
of
aspects of these Let me finish. Let me
finish what I'm saying.
>> Finish the Hadith.
>> Let me explain to you.
>> And and no, finish the last line. You're
skipping a lot.
>> Let to say that again.
>> No, that's not just a Hadith.
>> Let to say that again. Let to say that
again. Let to This is the Hadith. This
is the Hadith.
>> English okay?
>> English? English. Do not be like do not
be like them and do not believe them.
You can speak of Israel, Bani Israel,
yeah, with no issues.
>> No, that's not what he says.
That's not what he says, Hadith.
Okay, let me let me teach you.
>> Teach me what, man?
>> I got you.
I got you. This means do not be like
them and do not believe them. Which
means that there's aspects of what's in
circulation
in the Jews.
This is why this is important Hadith.
I got you. He says, do not believe them
nor disbelieve them, but say we have we
believe in what was revealed to us and
what is revealed to you.
>> Sure. Sure. Sure.
>> You just read it, didn't you?
>> Let us know what I do. What I do. The
point I'm making is
>> Am I correct?
>> Do not believe them. Do not believe
them. So the issue is this.
>> So what are they supposed to say?
>> Yeah. Yeah. And tell them that we
believe in what was revealed to Abraham
and Jacob and Isaac, etc. In the Quran
it's mentioned.
>> So he you're supposed to believe in what
they have and what you have, correct?
Look, you're caught lying on your own
Hadith.
>> So say again?
>> You're caught lying and misquoting your
own Hadith. I had to teach you what
>> What you talking about, man? Are you
stupid?
>> about what he taught you about.
>> The Quran says that the Hadith says that
don't be like them and don't believe
them. Which means that there's something
in circulation. There is something in
circulation from the kitab which is you
may remain agnostic about.
If the Quran contradicts it, then the
Quran takes precedence.
>> No, Muhammad never said that.
No.
No. No.
>> Clearly it's correcting something, isn't
it? In the New Testament.
>> Let let me touch on this cuz you're
messing up your Hadith.
>> Is the Quran correcting the New
Testament or not?
>> No, it is not. And and guess what?
Muhammad never
Let me ask you a question. Let me
answer.
>> Is the Quran correcting the New
Testament or
>> Ask
>> Let me answer. The answer is The answer
is no, and Muhammad never ever ever says
that the Quran is correcting the
previous scripture. In fact,
>> It doesn't say that. I said is the Quran
doing or not?
>> Let me finish, brother. You got to let
me finish, man.
Let me finish, brother.
You got to let me finish, man.
Let me finish, man.
>> Let me ask you the question first. Let
me ask you the question.
>> You trying to jump out the pot, dude.
Stop trying to jump out the pot like the
rest, man. Stay in there.
>> Hold on for a second, Avery. Otherwise,
we can't we can't speak over each other.
Let me ask you the
>> You're speaking over me.
>> I can't You You're not letting me speak.
>> I just let you finish and ask me a
question. You didn't even let me finish
my answer.
>> Let me Let me tell you I'm going to ask
you the question. Let me ask you
>> So, you're about to ask and let me
speak, right?
You're going to You're going to give me
an answer after I ask you the question,
right?
>> I qualify my answer, though?
>> Can you let me ask you the question so
you can answer?
>> but I want to know if
>> Sure. Let me ask you the question. Don't
be too scared. Don't be worried. Don't
be nervous. I know you're nervous. You
must be scared because you don't even
let me ask you the
>> That doesn't work on me. Are you Can you
Can you assure me that when
Can you assure me that I will be allowed
to answer you in full?
>> Let me just ask you the question.
>> Will you allow me to answer the question
in full?
>> Let me ask you the question. Let me ask
you the question.
>> So, I'm going to answer in full when you
ask.
>> Okay. So, you're not letting me say
anything, yeah?
>> I'm letting you go. I'm just saying I'm
going to answer in full.
>> When the Quran says, "Wama massahu min
lughubin," yeah? That no weariness
touched God. That Allah
He created the heavens and the earth.
And
no weariness touched him, yeah? Is that
a correction of the Genesis
and Exodus narrative or not? Yes or no?
Is it correcting what's in the hands of
the Bible or not? Is it correcting or
not?
>> I'm going to answer you in full. The
answer is no. It is not a correction. It
It No, it is not a correction. The Bible
doesn't even teach
that
No, it doesn't
It
>> He even teach that tiredness for
a touch to God. In fact, it talks about
him ceasing working on the seventh day,
not that he was actually tired. So, if
you knew your own Bible, you'd know the
first verse in Exodus number
10. If you knew your own Bible, you'd
know that there's a verse in Exodus
number 10.
You must be scared, BOY.
YOU MUST BE SCARED, BOY.
LET ME FINISH.
SO, BACK to the Hadith.
The Hadith that you were referring to
where it says, "Don't believe what they
say, nor disbelieve what they say, but
this is what you respond to them."
We believe Let me finish.
No, you're the one who changed the
subject. You brought this Hadith up.
You brought this Hadith up, but now
you're getting schooled. Now you're
getting cooked. Now you're getting
burned.
He says, "Say, believe in what was
revealed to us." We believe in what was
revealed to us.
And what was revealed to us?
So, hold on.
Are you going to listen or not? No, are
you going to listen? I already listened
to you.
Okay. Are you? So, answer the question.
>> Let me tell you what I'm saying, and
then you can say what you want to say.
>> Okay.
>> You said that Let me speak, man. Just
give me 20 seconds.
If you if it's not a dialogue if if we
can't speak to each other.
>> You're the only one speaking over me,
Hadith.
>> If you let me speak for 20 seconds, then
you can respond for 20 seconds.
Otherwise, you're trying to you you got
it.
Okay. So, what I'm trying to say is that
in the book of Genesis, it's mentioned,
yeah, that God rested. However, in the
book of Exodus, chapter number 31, verse
number 17, okay? In that verse, the word
is that he not only rested, but he
refreshed. And the Hebrew word is
nafash. So, here clearly in the Old
Testament corpus, you have this idea of
God actually literally resting. If you
find If you look at all of the the the
the the rabbinical commentary about
that, it's an actual rest. So, the point
is this. You're saying, when the Quran
says Muhammad
in chapter number
in Surat Qaf that is not correcting
this. So what is it correcting then? Why
is it mentioning that?
All right.
>> So again
the
author of the Quran is actually
unfamiliar with what is in the Bible. He
only goes by word of mouth.
You said that I can speak. You notice
how you said I can speak. I let you
speak uninterrupted.
>> Okay, go ahead.
>> I already answered you. No, it is not a
correction. Muhammad is ignorant of what
is in the previous scriptures and he's
only going by word of mouth. Here's an
example. The example is what you brought
up in the Hadith that you had no idea
about. The Hadith says that you're
referring to it says that the Jews used
to recite the Torah in Hebrew and then
explain it in Arabic.
>> Okay, so before you get to the Hadith
for a second
>> Let me finish. Let me finish.
>> Okay, I'm giving you 20 seconds. Go on,
speak.
>> I appreciate it. So according to the
Hadith that you brought up it destroys
you because it shows that they're
hearing by word of mouth. They're having
the Torah explained to them in Arabic by
some of the Jews. Then in response
Muhammad says, don't believe what they
say nor disbelieve what they say but in
response say, we believe in what was
revealed to us and what was revealed to
you. So they can't trust the Jews on if
they're lying or not of what their
scripture say because they don't know
it. They don't know the scriptures
themselves. They're only going by word
of mouth. So Muhammad is not correcting
nothing. He's ignorant of the
scriptures.
>> So I've let you speak. Is it my turn to
respond?
>> Thank you. I appreciate it. Finally.
>> Yeah, fine.
>> By the way, don't forget that Muhammad
point
because I'm going to show you that
Muhammad is the one that said that
Muhammad was the Muhammad over the
Quran.
>> Let me speak. Let me respond.
I've given you one example, okay? One
example is in the book of Exodus chapter
number 31 and the book of Genesis
chapter number one. There's this idea of
rest. Now you can say Genesis is not
rest is ceasing to work but you can't
say that with the book of Exodus.
And therefore the Quran says in more
than one occasion by the way. Actually
says this many times. And so al-A'raf
it mentions
in chapter number 50 it mentions
weariness touch tiredness touched him.
So clearly there's a correction going on
but you don't want to believe that no
problem. The Quran says
the Quran clearly is responding to a
biblical narrative. It's clearly
responding to a Christian narrative.
It's saying they did not kill him they
did not crucify him.
It was made to appear
as if they did. So the question is this.
Is the Quran with this verse
is it aware of what is being said by
Christians? Is this correct that they
say that he he was killed and crucified?
Is that a correct representation? And is
it then correcting that or not? Yes or
no?
>> Beautiful. So now I get to fully answer.
So this is what you're this is notice
the difference.
The answer is yes. Here's a quick answer
to yes. Yes, it is correcting what
people
say. Yeah, now we're talking. It's
correcting what they say not what the
scriptures say. But the Christians and
the Jews. So notice how notice how let
me let me land. I let you speak
uninterrupted right? So thank you I
appreciate it. So notice the difference.
At first you were arguing that Muhammad
is aware of what the scripture says and
is correcting the scripture not just
what the Jews and Christians say. But
you just changed your question to is
Muhammad aware of what the Christians
say and is therefore correcting what the
Christians say and the answer to that is
yes. Unbeknownst to him that what they
are saying is actually in the Injil in
the gospel. So Muhammad is going against
the Christians unknowingly going against
the gospel. And here's the point.
No I'm I'm going to land land. Keep keep
talking actually it's it's good that
I didn't realize this but I PROBABLY
SHOULD.
I DIDN'T REALIZE THIS BUT ACTUALLY
PLEASE KEEP TALKING. Keep talking man.
Oh thank you. This is good. So what
you're going to have to do thank you. So
this is what you're going to have to
deal with. What you're going to have to
deal with is Muhammad commanding you not
to just not to believe what we say or
disbelieve what we say. Notice he never
goes against the scripture. Show me
anywhere anywhere where Muhammad says
don't believe in what the scripture
says. Show me one time where Muhammad
said that.
This is the point. Please answer.
>> Hold on. This is what you said. You said
that it was a correction. Okay.
It was a correction. You you admitted.
You actually I'm surprised and I have to
I have to commend you actually.
I thought you'd be a belligerent young
man.
Okay. I thought you know you put on the
heart. You put
I have to say you're better than I
thought you'd be.
You're better than I thought you'd be.
You you do you do you do have a future
in in in in in content creation and in
influencing. You do have a future in
this. And you you know what? There's
some I'm starting to like him.
Yeah. I'm starting to like him. Yeah.
He's got some he's got some good
qualities.
>> That's usually the effect I have on
people.
>> Okay. It don't just follow like that
because you look like a buck a buck
tooth
buckaroo.
We're just having a we're having we're
having a good time.
>> This is I'm a humble staff. I like to
cook giant.
>> But let me just say this to you, right?
The point I'm making to you is is is
this. You have just admitted when the
Quran says
when they should be alone.
>> Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa. I didn't say
anything about
>> No no no no no. Let me finish what I'm
saying. Let me finish.
>> But you just misrepresented me. I never
said about anything in
>> I didn't even say anything yet.
>> Yes you did. You said that what I
admitted that what the Quran says I
never said anything about the Quran
says. We're talking about what Muhammad
said about the
>> I haven't finished my sentence. So you
would not you you couldn't have known
what I'm saying.
I said when the Quran when the Quran
said
They did not kill him. They did not
crucify him. What was made to appear to
them that that was the case. Yeah, you
admitted that that was what you thought
was a correction of Muhammad of the
Christian community. But you thought he
didn't know what's in the New Testament.
Okay, you didn't know what's in the New
Testament. Yeah, it's still a correction
somehow. The point is is the crucifixion
mentioned in the New Testament. Yes, the
crucifixion is without a doubt mentioned
in the New Testament and it's mentioned
multiple times in multiple reports. It
says in the Quran that it was made to
appear to them that it was the case. It
didn't really happen. This is a
correction of the Quran which shows the
author of the Quran whether you believe
it's the Prophet Muhammad or we believe
it's Allah. The author of the Quran was
fully aware of what was in that book and
he was fully aware what was in
circulation with Christians and Jews and
not only did he reject it, he corrected
it. Is that true or is that false?
>> False again. So I don't know I I don't
know how many times you want me to
answer this for you hijab.
I don't know how many times you want me
to answer this. I'll I'll break it down
and remember I'm going to break it down
in in unqualified terms and maybe this
will help you out.
What we're talking about is what
Muhammad is saying regarding what the
people say not the scriptures. So when
the Quran says oh they
this is the example.
For their boasting For their boasting we
killed the Messiah. We killed the Hold
on a second. For their boasting this is
chapter 4 about the crucifixion verse.
For their boasting
They say we killed the Messiah son of
son of son of Mary. Notice this
please listen. I need you to pay
attention this time so you can learn
this.
The Quran is addressing what people are
saying. It's never addressing what the
scriptures themselves say. Why? Because
Muhammad didn't know.
Because he was ignorant. What you need
to do, Hijab, what you need to do this
is what I need you to do. This is what I
need you to do.
What I need you to do let me finish.
You can ask it after I'm done.
Ask it after I'm done.
No, ask
No, I need more time than that because
you didn't have like 15 seconds left.
Let me speak. When when I when I finish,
I'm good.
Okay.
I appreciate it. So, we're talking about
what they say, not what the scriptures
say. What you would need to do for me,
Hijab, is give me any Hadith. You got
thousands to pick from. Give me any
Hadith where Muhammad talks about or
discredits what the scriptures say, not
what the people say. That's number one.
Number two, what I would like for you to
do is show me where the Quran say uh
critiques what the scripture says. It
says, "This is in the scripture." And
then it and then it goes on to correct
or address what the scripture says uh
and says that that's wrong. Okay? Don't
show me cuz this is all we have. Over
and over and over
I promise I'm about to land. What we
have in the Quran and from Muhammad,
Muhammad says in Jami al-Tirmidhi 26:53,
he says that the Injil and the Torah are
with the Jews and the Christians. What
the Quran says in chapter 2 verse 41,
chapter 2 verse 89, chapter 2 verse 91,
chapter 4 verse
chapter 4 verse 101, it says the Quran
is confirming what is with them. Never
do we ever see one unambiguous statement
one unequivocal verse where the Quran is
correcting the previous scriptures
textually.
Hadith or Quran.
Does the Quran mention that that's in
the scripture?
You did interrupt me a little bit.
Okay, so is it my turn now to kind of
respond? Yeah, sure. If you can answer
that. If you can answer my question
directly.
>> So, yeah. The point is
>> Is it a yes or no?
>> I made this point to the your previous
the previous guest that we had.
>> So, no.
>> When I was saying that whenever the
Quran mentions, for example, the
probably the clearest verse is in I'll
help you with it. Yet you do not know
who
I and them in the Torah and the Injil,
yeah? Which is that they see the prophet
mentioned with them, okay? With them.
So, it indicates there's something going
on with them that they have something
with them, right?
>> The Injil and the Torah says explicitly
>> Yeah, so it's it's Torah and Injil,
there's an aspect of that which is with
them. Now, the question is this.
>> Where does it say that?
>> Can I Can I finish, please?
>> Sorry. I just didn't I didn't know we
were butchering texts.
>> Okay, butchering texts. I'll explain to
you why it's not butchering texts cuz
these are things I've learned when I was
in university, when I was doing the
Azhar degree for
>> You learned You learned it from an
Orthodox Muslim, nice.
>> No, no, no. I No, I learned this what
I'm going to tell you now. An Orthodox
Muslim did teach me a few things as
well, actually. We sat down and had a
conversation
>> I'm starting to like this guy.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> I'm starting to like this guy. You got
to You got to love him, man.
>> What do you mean?
>> I'm starting to like you, man.
>> Orthodox Muslim is my guy, brother. He's
He's He's our guy, brother.
>> I'm starting to like you, man.
>> You think I have a problem with with
with a person who has a problem with a
person who has a problem with a person
who has a problem with a person who has
a problem with a person who has a
problem with a person who has a problem
with a person who has a problem with a
person who has a problem
>> Yeah, so where in the text does it say
that?
>> In our religion, we we we take knowledge
from whoever.
>> Yes.
>> In fact,
>> Nice. So, where does it say that they
have aspects of that in
>> that someone who is Two people don't
learn.
You're one of them, by the way.
>> Which one am I?
>> There's a shy person, the other one's
the arrogant person. So, let me tell you
this.
>> Oh, so you're the arrogant person, huh?
>> There's two people who don't They learn.
>> Right. The arrogant but you just
described yourself.
>> Yeah, sure, sure. Maybe you're right
about that, actually. You're probably
right.
>> No, it's not me.
>> Okay, putting that to the side for now.
Let me ask you Let me tell you this.
>> Okay.
>> What I learned when I was in university
was that there's a principle called
itlaqul kulli alal juz.
Yeah, which is that using the whole to
refer to a part of a thing. So, for
example, yeah? In the Quran in chapter
12 it says
ask the town. Okay, ask the town. What
it means to say is ask the people of the
town. But this is a rhetorical device
that's mentioned. So the whole town is
represented by a part of the town is
represented by the whole of the object.
Number one. Number two in the Quran it
says in chapter 71
that they put their fingers in their
ears, right? Now they don't put their
entire fingers in their ears, they put a
part of the fingers in their ears. So
the point the point is in English you
call this
part in
Tatum pro part in, yeah. Tatum pro part
in which is the idea of using a general
statement to talk about a whole of a
thing. So if I say the United States won
the match or if I say that England won
the match, it doesn't mean every single
person in the country won the match. So
the point is this, this principle super
extends to all of those instances in the
Quran where indicates that okay, it
speaks in generic terms. When it says
or
or any of those terms meaning with them,
it indicates a part of those things not
the whole of the thing. Okay. So unless
you're able to undo this principle which
is a principle and not just in Arabic
linguistics but in all of the languages
in the world actually including English,
yeah, then you don't have a case
unfortunately. As I said, the the
scholars of Islam, people like
Al-Asqalani
they have made it very clear that they
believe that what's in with the
Christians and the Jews today is
corrupt.
>> Wait, wait, which scholars?
>> Which scholars?
>> said.
>> In
Al-Asqalani mentions that we and our
friends, he says this
that me and our friends say that what's
in the hands of the
the Christians men to us and in jail is
for the end is it is
it is distorted texturally.
>> That's what I Can you show us the
reference?
>> Yeah, it's in Fath al-Bari. I can
>> Can you pull it up?
>> I can't right now. I'm drinking my tea.
I'm sitting down. You can find it. You
think I'd lie to you about that or I'm
lying?
>> You've been lying You've been lying this
whole time.
>> This is uncontroversial, Avery. This is
>> Okay. So,
Let me show you why this is
controversial.
>> No, I know there are some scholars that
it's not corrupted. I know there are
some scholars who didn't believe that. I
KNOW THAT.
>> AH.
>> YEAH, I KNOW THAT.
>> I KNOW THERE are some
I'm loving I'm loving I'm loving your
honesty. So, there's some scholars who
believe in textual corruption and
there's some scholars who believe in
wholesale preservation. That's
beautiful. Good job. Good job, Ahmed.
>> mean you don't believe in Let me tell
you this. So, Ibn Taymiyyah believed in
the following. He didn't believe in
wholesome preservation. He believed that
he compared in his what do you call it?
Jawwab al-Saheeh. He had a whole kitab
or a whole book called the
uh correct response to the Jews and the
Christians, right? And in this book,
basically, he says this. He says the
similitude of the Bible, okay, is like
the similitude of the weak hadith.
Okay, so we we treat the Bible like we
treat weak hadith. And that's considered
to be a strong version.
>> What does Bukhari
Huh? What does Bukhari say?
>> Bukhari, there's a difference of opinion
about him. Like, so for example, Ibn
Hajar, Ibn Hajar, who obviously is
interpreting al-Bukhari, because Fath
al-Bari is an interpretation of
al-Bukhari, yeah? Ibn Hajar says that
al-Bukhari has this view which indicates
that they may have had some kind of
preserved text at the time.
>> Mhm. Okay.
>> He indicates that they may have
>> He didn't say may have. He says they
definitely had.
>> What Ibn Hajar says that. I don't think
he says that. He I don't He's unsure
about it. But what I'm saying to you is
that you can interpret Bukhari maybe
like that. Yeah, you can. But what I'm
saying to you is
>> Huh? Bukhari, that's what he says.
>> Some scholars of Islam might have
believed in this. I'm not negating this
point. The Jews and Christians at the
time of the prophet had some kind of
preserved text.
>> So, this So, this means that our
position is is completely Islamic that
the scriptures are uncorrupted.
>> Some scholars of classical scholars of
Islam might have believed that. But as I
said to you,
as I said Yeah, of course, I have to be
intellectually honest. What do you think
this is uh
I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
The point I'm making to you is
The point I'm making to you is this,
it's very clear that the scholars, the
overwhelming vast majority of Muslim
scholars believed that what's in the
hands of the Christians and the Jews is
corrupt. That is clear.
>> You said majority?
>> The overwhelming vast majority.
>> Of the early Muslims?
>> Pardon?
>> Sorry?
>> Of the early Muslims?
>> The overwhelming vast majority of
classical scholars throughout the
medieval period, throughout the early
scholars, the like Ibn Ibn Hazm had a
very staunch view. He he what do you
call it? He wrote Al-Fisal in the 4th
century, the 5th century. He believed
that it's like toilet paper. It's like
nothing. He believed the Bible of the of
the time
of his people was was very distorted.
That's what he believed.
>> What is your What is your evidence that
the majority of the early scholars of
Islam
believe that the previous scriptures
were
>> My evidence is what Ibn Hajar
al-Asqalani mentions in Fath al-Bari,
where he said that our
>> Bukhari said something else.
>> Ibn Hajar is is interpreting Ibn
Bukhari. He's the number one person who
interprets Bukhari in the world in the
history of Islam.
>> Bukhari explicitly says that
>> You asked me to give you a reference.
I'm giving you the one of the most
premier and gold standard references in
Islam. You don't know it. You you don't
When was Ibn Hajar born? When was he
around?
>> That that means nothing. All of that is
irrelevant.
>> You don't know these people. You don't
know these That's the thing. You don't
know these people. You don't know these
things. You don't know these things.
>> We know Bukhari, don't we?
>> You know Bukhari, but you That's all you
know, yeah?
>> So So Bukhari and other
>> He's calling him an ass.
Uh yeah, yeah. Ibn Abbas doesn't say
anything about this. Ibn Abbas doesn't
You're all over the place. You're over
the place.
I know I know the the the Hadith in
Bukhari about Ibn Abbas. I know
>> Ah, nice then. So you
>> And it's actually against the Hadith
that's against you. But the point I'm
making to you is this.
>> Okay.
>> The Hadith is against you, but let's
stop going from pillar to post. The
point I'm making is this, it's simple,
it's simple. The overwhelming
vast majority of Muslim proof scholars
from the classical period until now
believe that this Bible that we have in
our hands is correct.
>> Show me that. Don't just say that. I
don't believe you.
>> of that and the reference
And the reference of that is Ibn Hajar
al-Asqalani.
>> Show us. Brother, you you can't be
making this claim. You can't be making
it.
>> I don't What do you mean show you? I
don't
>> What do you mean you got all those books
behind you and then you don't got a a
reference? You don't got the source that
you can show me?
>> me in this uh house. This is quite
pathetic. You're asking me to go and get
you a
uh
>> I'm asking you to provide evidence for
what you're saying, not just claiming
it, cuz I can't trust anything you're
saying.
>> we can get someone from the from the
from the chats to get it. It's It's in
Fath al-Bari and it starts like this.
Like I remember I memorized the first
part.
>> says that the majority of the
>> I memorized the first part of it. This
is the best you're going to get. And for
me to even memorize, yeah, this is
surprising. Waqa'd sarraha ba'du
ashabina
that some of our friends, meaning when
he says our friends, he means the
Shafi'is.
anna
ma bayna aydi that what is in the hands
>> Some of our friends.
>> al-Yahud wa an-Nasara, yeah, what is in
the hands of the day of the Jews and the
Christians is corrupted. And he mentions
it what kind of corruption is it? He
goes on to say
>> majority
>> He goes on to say it's altered and
corrupted from a textual
perspective.
>> see that because according to other
scholars, as you already agreed, they
don't hold that position.
>> I I I don't know what to do I don't know
what to do for you right now. I I just
I'm
>> I appreciate let me let me Arabic talk,
bro. You just spoke for a long time. Let
me respond.
Goodness.
>> So, you don't know about this.
>> Just as you agreed that there's other
scholars There's the other side of
Islamic scholarship that disagree with
that position, which and you're saying
some of He says some of our friends
where they believe in wholesale
preservation of the scriptures. And they
quote verses, the same verses that we
use today that none can alter the words
of Allah. They They even use the Hadith
that a lot of Muslims today try to say
is is not authentic. Sunan Abu Dawud 449
where Muhammad puts the Torah in the
judgment seat. They use these arguments
to substantiate.
>> Right.
>> The side that says
>> Some believe in the preservation.
You're right. There's no
>> The side that says
>> You're right on that point.
>> scriptures. I know I'm right on that.
Thank you for telling me. I appreciate
it.
>> There are some
There are some scholars who believed
that the the the Bible and sorry, the
Torah and the Injil was preserved at the
time of the prophet.
>> Yes. Exactly.
>> They they did They That was a minority
view. Okay, that is a minority view.
>> It's like this. Look.
>> Look, let me tell you this. In the
Quran, there's two types of scholars.
Some of them believe the earth was flat
and some of them believe the earth was
round.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. So,
they looked at the verses of the Quran.
Some of them looked at the verses of the
Quran, they believed the earth was flat
because of them. And some of them looked
at the verses of the Quran, they said
the earth was round because of them.
Likewise, some people looked at the
verses of the Quran they and the vast
majority of them interpreted it as
tahrif ma'nawi and lafzi. That it is a
distortion of the text both in text and
in meaning, okay? And a minority of them
believed, like you said, which but
you've exaggerated the claim. No, no,
no. You You said that and I will admit
it. It's true, yeah, that some of the
scholars of Islam
>> Heavy scholars.
>> Sorry?
>> Heavy scholars, right?
>> Well, I mean, that's it's up for debate
whether Bukhari mentioned that or not.
It's up for debate about that. No, it's
it's No, it is up for debate. I looked
at the the text of the text myself. I I
don't know what he says about that. It's
it's hard You can make a case for or
against.
>> You've got to even make a case.
>> way, either way, either way,
Ibn Taymiyyah has a strong view on it.
He says that the What do you call it?
The Bible is like the weak Hadith.
Ibn Hajar says that the majority of
people that Al Al What do you call it?
Ibn Hazm has a very strong view.
>> Ibn Ibn Taymiyyah believed that most of
it was preserved.
>> Yeah, he did say that.
>> Mhm.
>> He believed that most of it was
preserved, but he said that the rest of
it was like weak Hadith and stuff like
that and he mentions the parts of the
Bible which he believed were incongruent
with the Quran and he, unlike what you
said today, said these can't be from
God. Okay?
>> Right.
>> So he has a whole book on that called
the Jaw al-Saeer.
>> All right. Which is which is something
that we
>> way, Ibn Hazm, I got the reference here
for you. I got the reference for you.
Volume 1, page 161. Okay? And he says
that it's our view that there's no
disagreement against
on the companions on this matter of
there being a change. So Ibn Hazm is a
early scholar
>> aspect?
>> He believes logically. He believes he
believes it's changed in a textual
aspect.
>> Does he say that?
>> Yeah, he does say that. He Ibn Hazm is
very clear about it.
>> read the quote cuz you said you got the
verse the the reference up. Can you read
it out for me?
>> you can you can go to that. I've just
told you that he believes that. You can
go and and check the volume. So you get
the volume in the the thing.
>> It doesn't have it.
>> one of the guys to pull it up for us.
But you're asking me to pull out, well,
you know, quote exact quotations.
>> You said you got the reference.
>> becoming now it's becoming ridiculous
actually.
>> It's ridiculous for me to ask for a
source and what you're claiming.
>> No no problem. I'll get you the quotes
that you want. I will get them. I'll get
someone to get you the exact quotation.
>> ridiculous?
>> No no no, but I don't have the books
with me all all of a sudden.
>> Then then respectfully don't mention it
if you're not ready to present it.
>> No, what do you mean? I've just
mentioned the the name of the book and
the volume. If you want me to read the
exact quotation, what what do you want?
>> This is this is why I'm saying this
Sajad is because earlier when you were
referencing the Hadith when you were
referencing the Hadith, you misquoted
the Hadith, you didn't know what the
Hadith said, you only knew a part of it,
but you didn't know what the whole
Hadith said. This is why
>> This is not a misquote. You said a
reference or a quote. Now, this what you
said was the Hadith said. The Hadith the
Prophet himself said, "Let us
not let us not believe them." And then
the part of it which is that don't
believe them, don't believe them. The
other part of it wasn't Hadith, was
actually a verse of the Quran. He
recited a verse of the Quran.
>> In the Hadith, right?
>> In the Hadith, yes.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah yeah yeah.
You asked me about the Hadith. The
Hadith is not we differentiate between
the Hadith and the Quran. That's why you
mistake mistake
>> Muhammad quoted the Quoran verse in the
Hadith. What are you even talking about?
>> This is this Hadith in here?
Okay, so do you want me to read this for
you?
>> Yes.
>> Okay, let me see this
So he says it says it is this is he says
that
kitāb. They wrote another book with
their hands, yeah?
But they said this is he's he's he is
doing tafsir of an ayah which is you
know the ayah chapter
>> 279 Yes.
>> Yes, 279 which says that
>> So they wrote a different book.
>> Yes, he's he's he's interpreting that.
He's saying that it's a distortion of
the text. Do you understand?
>> No no So this is my this is my issue cuz
I understand what you're saying. My
issue is this. In that writing
interpretation doesn't exist or or what?
No, cuz this is what I'm saying. Writing
what you just read doesn't tell me that
he believed that the Torah was textually
corrupted simply because they wrote
another book and tried to sell it for a
small price. You have multiple
interpretations on this matter.
You mentioned Ibn Jarir earlier with
Brother, let me finish.
Allow me to finish. This is insane.
Ibn Ibn Jarir talks about this and talks
about how they wrote another book with
their own hands.
Every we're going to read it for you and
then moving on after this. You go ahead.
>> Okay, how can you ask the people of the
book about something while the while
your book which is was revealed to his
messenger
>> That's another Hadith, right?
>> Sorry.
>> That's a that's a Hadith, right?
>> You're asking me to to references,
right?
You asked me to provide references. I'm
reading the references and you're now
you're complaining.
>> What is this Is this reference the
Hadith? Is this Sahih al-Bukhari?
>> Which that Quoran you're everything.
>> Bro, let's read it and let's move on.
It's too scary.
>> Okay, just leave this. I I mean to be
honest with you,
what are you laughing at? What are you
laughing at? There's no There's nothing
to read the source. There's nothing to
There's Look, Avery, you're not You're
not winning anything here.
>> Generally speaking, hey, whatever you
say, man.
>> Do you understand? Do you understand
what I'm saying to you right now? I know
this is high level. You wouldn't be
allowed in my class, brother.
And this is what happens when you bring
people You wouldn't be allowed in my
class because you're not understanding.
>> You said that the quote earlier
>> giving you a simple question. I'm asking
you a simple Do you understand that
>> reading in Ibn Hazm?
>> a question? Can I ask you a question?
>> Why would you keep messing up the
references?
>> Do you understand that in Islamic
scholarship that there are two views,
one majority and one minority, and the
majority
>> I disagree with you saying majority, but
I do agree that there are two views on
>> Beautiful. Beautiful. Excellent, Avery.
>> I know I know scholars that say that
there
they're preserved.
>> What you said is not unreasonable. What
you said is not unreasonable.
>> Thank you.
>> said is not unreasonable. Whether or not
you believe it's the majority or
minority view
you still believe there are two views,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> a Muslim If a Muslim takes the view that
the the book that we have today is
corrupt, which is what scholarship
modern scholarship has already
established, as you know.
>> They haven't established it. That's
their opinion.
>> Yeah, they have established it. Like
Bart Ehrman and all these What do you
call it? Bruce Metzger
>> who affirms the Quran corruption.
>> Yeah, yeah. What you You haven't even
got a single diploma to your name, and
you're talking about
>> Oh, but he was on your page saying that
laughing in your face saying
>> Anyway, anyway, anyway.
>> He was laughing in your face.
>> Anyway, anyway. So, the the the point is
>> He was crucified.
You know, we definitely have a
conversation for that.
You remember that.
>> I'm saying you You said You said it now,
and we can end at this, and then we can
move on to Christianity because you you
trying to avoid Christianity.
Islam is there.
>> Hold on.
>> So, so so
>> We're done with Christianity, yeah?
>> I know I helped you answer the question.
We're We're done.
I'm not answering your question.
>> We've cleared up all your doubts. Now
here's the
>> You didn't clear You didn't clear up
anything.
>> We can agree
>> Hold on for a second.
>> Can I respond what you said?
>> I haven't even said anything yet.
>> You haven't even made your point yet.
What is this?
>> Give a second. Give me a second. You
said that you you accept that there are
two views. One view that it's partially
What do you call it? Corrupt from a
textual perspective and the other one
that it's not corrupt from a textual
perspective, correct?
>> That is
>> I accept that. That's That's a clever
way of putting it. No problem. I'm
saying that this is the majority view
based on my reading. I don't think you
can access the books to even tell us
that this is the majority and the
minority because
>> I don't think you can, either.
>> You can't even translate it.
>> You couldn't even read the books that I
asked for that you were saying that you
couldn't
>> You can't even digitize it. I don't see
how you can read this and how you can
know this.
>> You don't know the Arabic language.
>> Yes, yes, the the teacher couldn't bring
me the reference. You couldn't bring me
the source.
>> Well, hold on. Hold on. I'm being
>> And you said you were reading from Ibn
Hajar, but skipped and started reading
from Ibn Hazm.
You said you were reading Ibn Hajar
earlier, but started reading from Ibn
Hazm.
>> People are giving me the source as well.
I read Ibn Hajar
>> This is That's pathetic.
>> Okay. Okay. I'll give you the Ibn Hajar
one if you want. I'll no problem. As a
as a goodwill favor, I'll give you the
Ibn Hajar one.
In fact, hold on. The the point is this
is that you've already conceded the
point, which is that there are two
views. So, if I now take this
>> that. That was my point.
>> Okay. What
>> I'm the one who brought it up. I'm the
one
>> All right. Whatever. Okay.
>> I yeah, no, it's not whatever.
>> Okay.
Whatever. All right. No problem.
>> I'm the one who had to teach you that
there were other big-time scholars who
said who disagreed with your
>> You had to teach me. You were so clever.
>> I taught you today.
>> I love my lesson. And the lesson is
this. The lesson is that there are two
views, okay? One view is that textual
distortion is there, and the other view
is that textual is it's not textual
distortion, but it's a distortion of
meaning. There's two views, okay? And
I'm saying that I take the view that
it's There is textual distortion. That's
just like there's two views just like
there's two views on the people looking
at the Quran, different scholars of
Islam in the past. Some of them said
that the earth was flat, and some of
them said that the earth was round. By
the way, nobody looked at the Bible and
said that the earth is round by virtue
of the fact of the verse of the Bible.
By virtue of the fact of the By the way,
the closest you have is the book of
Isaiah 20 verse number 22, which says
that the circle of the earth. But No,
no, hold on. So, just like you have
scholars you just like you have scholars
of Islam who looked at the verse of the
Quran, some of them said the earth was
round, and some of them said the earth
was
flat, and we take the view that the
earth is round, which corresponds with
the views of Ibn Taymiyyah and
Al-Ghazali and Ahmad ibn Hanbal and Ibn
Hazm and etc. etc. We do the same thing
with this issue here. So, so long as
Okay, yeah, beautiful.
Ibn Hajar. Ah, we got it.
Okay, thank you.
Is this Is this Is this thing?
Okay, okay.
Where's the other one?
Oh, no, right here it is. It's exactly
what I said. Subhanallah.
This is what This is what What do you
call it?
What's his name?
Actually, this is even worse for you.
Well, you call it my call of Bukhari.
You're right about that, and I tell you
that that's why he said. Yeah?
Can you
Let me Let me Let me Let me Let me
translate that. That our friends a a lot
of our friends companions mean the
Shafi'is,
Well,
let me finish. That the Jews and the
Christians
they changed the Torah and Injil. They
changed them, okay? Well,
Allah They even said because they
changed them, yeah, that you can you can
distort and you can rip up the verses of
the Bible.
Actually, it doesn't even say the Bible.
It says
Yeah, the verses of those distorted
texts. Well,
Al-Bukhari and Bukhari that this is goes
this goes against what? Al-Bukhari
mentioned. So this is you wanted a
reference. This is exactly done, right?
What do you want? Do you want Do you
want the page number? Do you want Do you
want Is it mentioned here?
>> Can you shout out the page number and
everything so we can look at that?
>> Uh what do you call it? It's page number
and the Jews is number 13 and uh the
paragraph is number 7,114.
>> don't Are we done?
>> Are we done?
>> No, just 1 second.
>> Is is you want more of a reference?
>> Yeah, can I respond now?
>> Can I Come on now.
You admit it now.
>> Can I respond?
>> You admit it now.
>> What? Another view?
>> You admit it now. Admit what?
>> Hold on, just 1 second. I got to be able
to respond to what he just said.
>> Let him respond then we go to
Christianity. Is that fair? Go on.
>> Yeah, that's fair.
Yeah, go on. Okay, so thank you for
finally bringing the source. Now we're
going to take a look at that to see what
it actually says in context. Um cuz I
you know, I you didn't put it on the
screen like we asked you to. Do you do
you read that 1 second? Notice how I let
you speak uninterrupted, right?
How can you speak a language that you
don't understand? If you're not afraid
of what I got to say, man, you got to
let me speak, bro.
>> Go on.
>> I appreciate it. So, when you when when
you say are you are you going to admit
it? Are you going to admit it? Admit
what?
We've already agreed together by your
own concession
>> Sure.
>> are two views from the scholars. There's
a view that some of them hold that the
scriptures are textually corrupted.
There's the other view that people like
Bukhari, Ibn Abbas, and others according
to Ibn Bukhari I'm sorry, according to
Bukhari uh quoting Ibn Abbas that the
scriptures are textually preserved and
they're only distorted in meaning, not
in text. So,
1 second.
>> Yeah.
>> So, in the time of Muhammad, according
to a lot of your big scholars, the
scriptures, as you already said, were
preserved in Muhammad's time.
Majority of them there's no
Please allow me to finish.
Yeah, no problem. allow me to finish.
Thank you, I appreciate it. This is what
this would mean because I I take this
view, the the view of Bukhari and
others.
But this is what this means. This means
that the scriptures that existed in
Muhammad's time, according to your
Islamic scholar, notice how they got to
keep interrupting. Brother, have some
self-control and let me talk.
Thank you. Have some self-control. You
put on a chef hat.
>> So, let me talk.
I got dressed for the occasion. I got
dressed for the occasion.
That's all.
What this means is
since according to by your concession,
the big scholars, some big scholars also
believed in full preservation of the
scriptures in Muhammad's time, this
means that according to those scholars,
what I have even to this day, Matthew,
Mark, Luke, John, Genesis, Exodus,
Leviticus, Numbers, Deuteronomy, the
writings of the prophets, everything
that they had in Muhammad's time that
they had in possession,
it's true,
is the authority is authoritative and is
the word of Allah and is the word
Bro, please, bro, please. If you can,
correct me when I'm done.
>> I will, I will do.
>> Okay, appreciate it.
So,
and here's the here's the the other fact
that we have to take into account, okay,
is that the side that believed in
preservation of the of the Bible, they
gave references from the Quran. They
knew the Quran and they used that
to prove their point. But from your
side, this is what what the problem is.
Your side of the spectrum, you guys have
no Quranic or Hadith proof to back up
that there's any textual corruption
>> Say it's about my pay grade.
>> You can't prove me wrong. Saying ah is
not a proof, it's not an argument.
>> Okay, do you want me to respond to you?
>> Can we have evidence for this, please?
>> Uh sure. So, what I've just I've just
given
You want evidences. I've given you a
reference and not only have I given you
the page number.
Okay, so no longer can you play this
game. I read it in the original
language.
>> Wait, what game?
>> Sorry? Sorry?
>> The The game that you're playing that
you're saying that they never referred
to a Hadith or Quranic verse is not
true. Because in fact, al-Bukhari,
sorry, Ibn Hajar al-Asqalani
>> say that, bro.
>> Okay, you said that they don't mention
Hadith verses Sorry, Hadith or verses of
Quran. That's what you said. So they
they don't They don't have
>> side is a scholarship. You said on my
side of the scholarship, they don't
mention a Quranic verse and they don't
mention Hadith.
>> My Oh, on your side. Sorry, yeah. So on
your on your on your side, there's no
Quranic What I said is there's no
Quranic
>> what you're saying.
So let me respond to that.
>> All right.
>> So what The answer to that is actually
they do mention it. And they usually
mention chapter 2 verse 79, yeah? And in
fact, al-Tabari himself mentions a
opinion like that in al-Tabari Tafsir
al-Tabari, where it says there's an
opinion that says Kitab ghayr al-Kitab.
>> What does he What does al-Tabari say
himself?
>> Al-Tabari doesn't do tafsir. He just
puts different names, okay?
>> Oh, he does. He gives his
>> That's what al-Tabari's view is. It's
not clear to me what al-Tabari's view
is.
>> tell you. I can teach it to you.
>> it's not clear to me. I've I've looked
at all the verses in question. It's not
clear to me.
>> Yeah, but would you like to know what he
says himself?
>> Al-Tabari says Al-Tabari mentions
something of Uthman ibn Affan. They They
dispute the authenticity of that Hadith
saying that it's Kitab ghayr al-Kitab,
etc.
>> We want to know what al-Tabari himself
said cuz he doesn't know what he said
that Torah has been corrupted.
>> Let me finish. Let me finish.
>> want to know what al-Tabari himself
>> Can you let me finish? Can you let me
finish so you can learn something from
this? Can you let me finish so you can
>> he's teaching you so far, man.
>> Okay, well, you can teach me without
access to the primary sources and I can
learn without access with the access to
the primary sources. Quite of an
asymmetrical lesson.
>> I have I have Ibn Jarir al-Tabari open
right now.
>> That's an asymmetrical lesson where I
have
>> like you actually have my sources ready
to go.
>> You don't have access to the primary
sources. That's an asymmetrical lesson,
all right?
>> I have al-Tabari open right now.
Al-Tabari al-Tabari right here.
>> Let me finish what I'm saying. Let me
finish what I'm saying.
>> Yeah.
>> Ibn Hajar al-Asqalani,
Ibn Hazm, and all of these other
scholars that I've mentioned with the
with the page number and the just number
and the paragraph number, all of those
guys, they mentioned this verse in
chapter number two, verse 79. Some of
them mentioned the verse in chapter
five, verse 13, 14. Yeah? Some of them
mentioned other verses. You have to
claim more than I. They do interpret the
Quran in that way, okay? Now, you can
say they don't, but that's just your
interpretation. Just like if someone
said, "Okay, there are some scholars
that say the Quran is flat." Yes,
al-Qurtubi believed the Quran that says
that the earth is flat.
But, Ibn Hazm believes that it says the
Quran says the earth is round. So, there
are two interpretations. Someone can
follow this one, and someone can follow
that one. It's not a matter where if you
Islam has one opinion on it. So, it
can't be an undercut for Islam. Do you
get it? It can't be an undercut for
Islam because there's more than one
legitimate opinion, and in my
estimation, it is the majority opinion.
Now, we're finished. Your strongest
argument has been complete. Now, it's
time for Christianity unless you want to
run away.
>> no, no, no, no, it's done. It's done.
>> It's done now. It's done now.
It's done now.
People can decide. People heard you.
People heard me.
>> Look, it's done now.
>> It's done now.
>> I can't quote al-Tabari just to land it.
>> No, no, no, we've we've we've spent a
lot of time on it.
>> I promise you I won't even give another
reference if that's it.
>> a lot of time on it. We've spent a lot
of time on it.
>> al-Tabari does not have 79 as a
corruption of the Quran.
>> People can decide. People can decide.
Every People can decide.
>> He says they wrote a book based on their
own interpretation.
>> Now, it's my
turn. I'll ask you this. Is Jesus fully
God?
Is Jesus fully God?
>> We we say that he's truly God.
>> No, is Jesus fully God? Is he Is he
fully God?
>> I already answered you. We don't say
fully as if there's percentages. We say
truly God.
>> Okay, is he fully God?
>> How many times do you want to answer
this?
>> No, no, is he fully God?
>> You're straw manning our position.
Please
>> Is Jesus
fully God? You see, look
>> I'll answer again.
We
>> We asked you a question. We asked you a
question. Is he truly God or not? We say
truly God.
>> Is Jesus truly God?
>> I'm not asking you whether he's truly
God or not.
>> Is Jesus truly God or not?
>> Is he truly God or not?
>> I already answered.
>> Yes or no?
>> Give me another question. I already
answered.
>> Yes or is is Jesus truly God or not?
>> I already answered.
Don't be scared.
>> Yeah, don't don't run. I'm an actual
Christian.
>> Is Jesus truly God or not?
>> We don't say truly God. We
say truly God.
>> Yes or no?
Yes or no? Yes or no?
Jesus
>> truly God or
>> all the essential properties to be God.
>> Now, deal with my deal with my
>> Is Jesus truly God? Is Jesus truly God
or not?
>> Deal with my position, please.
>> Is Jesus truly God or not?
>> Please deal with my position.
>> truly God or not?
>> I already answered you.
>> Yes or no?
>> Just wait until you deal with my
position.
>> Don't be scared now.
>> DEAL WITH MY POSITION.
>> IS JESUS TRULY God or not?
>> I want you to notice here, ladies and
gentlemen, this is how you know someone
is having they have to stick to the
script. Once you take them off their
script, they are cooked. They
don't know where to go.
They don't know where to go.
>> Is he truly God or
>> answered you on that.
>> Yes or no?
>> Asked and answered.
>> What is it?
>> Okay. Let me ask you this. Let me change
it because you you're you're not going
to
truly God or not.
Is he truly God or
>> He He possesses all the essential
properties that make God God.
>> Okay. So, when you say Jesus is is is
this statement true or false? Jesus is
God. Is it true or false statement?
>> That's a true statement.
>> Okay. Is he is Okay, excellent. Jesus is
God is a true statement, right?
>> I just said that.
>> Yeah, great. No problem. Is that is of
predication or identity?
>> It'll be a predication.
>> Okay. So, it's predication, is it? So,
he has the quality of being divine.
>> Yep.
>> He has the description of being divine.
>> Okay. So, that means to say that the
Father has this quality, the Son has
this quality, and the Holy Spirit has
this quality.
>> They they all have the essential
properties. They all have the divine
essence. They are all God by essence.
>> Uh
no problem. So, they all have the
quality of being divine, yeah?
>> They all have the nature.
>> Oh, okay, beautiful. And do they have a
will?
>> Yeah, they have the same will because
will is
will is a faculty of your essence.
>> Oh, wait a minute. Wait a minute. Wait,
hold on for a second.
So, they have the same will, do they?
>> That's what I said.
>> So, is the will
uh predicatively, okay,
uh does
uh God the Father have the same will in
a predicative sense as God the Son?
>> What Why would you say in a predicative
sense? What do you mean by by that?
>> Because you're mixing between Latin
Trinitarianism and three-self
Trinitarianism, social Trinitarianism.
You're mixing between
>> that?
>> Yeah, let me explain. Because No, let me
explain this to you, right? Is if you're
saying that the Father is God from a
predicative perspective, yes?
If he's God from a predicative
perspective, that means he has a center
of consciousness which is different from
the Son. Is that correct?
>> Based on what?
>> Because you you've just said it's
predicative, it's not identity, is it?
>> Yeah, so what what is what How does it
follow
>> understand the words I'm using?
>> I don't know about I don't think you do.
If Jesus is God by predication, just
real quick. If Jesus is God by
predication because he derives the
divine essence from the Father. Just let
me finish, bro.
>> I don't understand it.
>> Why Why Why Why you get so
uncomfortable? Why you get so
uncomfortable? You don't even understand
the questions you're asking.
>> understand if Jesus is fully God, you
could
>> If Jesus If Jesus because he derives his
source from the Father and the divine
essence of the Father, and so therefore
is predicated the divine essence, how
does that entail or conclude that he has
a different will than the Father?
>> separate center of consciousness to the
Son or not?
>> Correct. What Why? What Why I don't
understand.
>> I'm asking What do you mean why? I'm
asking you a question.
>> the same They have the same mind and
will, brother. They have the same center
of consciousness. Same mind and will.
>> They have the same mind, they have the
same will. Do they have the same essence
as well? They have the same essence.
>> I said. Every time you going to ask me
the same question.
>> Okay, they have the same mind, they have
the same will, they have the same
essence. Do they have the same
attributes?
>> Yes.
>> Aha. So, now you've moved to is of
identification because I identity
because now actually if they're the same
in essence and they're same in mind and
they're same in consciousness and
they're same in will and they're same in
attributes, that means that they're one
in the same person, aren't they?
>> No, there's a relative identity. They're
identical in essence but not identical.
There's a distinction in their
personhood.
>> Wait, wait, hold on, hold on. Hold on.
>> This this doesn't work.
This this this argument probably worked
back in like what, 2017?
>> Wait, hold on, let let me take it step
by step because
>> Go ahead, take it step by step. We're
going to dismantle this step by step.
>> Don't pretend, don't pretend that
Christianity has not been struggling
with this for two
>> It has It hasn't. This this argument
>> Okay, no problem. Yeah, we've just been
pretending We've We've just been looking
at different things. There's different
models. If you write now the Trinity on
Stanford Encyclopedia, you'll see Latin
Trinitarianism, Social Trinitarianism.
There's views of this. You mentioned
relative identity. Do you know who
mentions that relative identity?
Who Who's written
Peter Geach has written about it
recently, actually. Yeah, relative
identity. Actually
>> What What does it have to do with What
does it have to do with
>> about essence and sapience, so join us
next
>> He's going to
>> What What What does it have to do
>> Are you Are you going to refute Peter
Geach or something or
>> You don't know what he says. What does
he say? What does Peter Geach
>> I I I just asked you if you're going to
Are you going
>> What does he say? If you talk about
identity,
what does Peter Geach say?
>> What What What is my position?
>> What is You said relative identity, so I
don't know what Peter Geach said.
>> So, So, in in regard in regards to my
position, how are you refuting the
Trinity?
>> No, I'm asking You said relative
identity. That's associated with Peter
Geach. Do you know what he said?
>> So, what? I don't I don't care who
>> Okay, so you don't even know what you're
talking about, do you?
>> If I If I hold the position of relative
identity,
hold on. If I hold the position of
relative identity, what is your argument
against it?
>> Do you Do you Do you hold the position
of relative identity of Peter Geach? Do
you or not?
So So if you hold the position of
relative identity of Peter Geach, my
response to it is the following. My
response to it is in order for you to
come to that conclusion, you have to
have a relative identity framework. And
the relative identity framework goes
against predicate and propositional
logic. And in particular, it goes
against Leibniz's law. Which means that
in order for you to prove the Trinity,
you have to allow contradictions. Do you
Do you agree Do you agree with that?
>> No. Uh Can you
>> You have to reject propositional logic.
You have to reject classical logic.
>> Hold on. What What What is Leibniz's
law?
>> It's the law of identity.
>> No. It's a specific law of identity. Can
you tell me exactly what Leibniz's law
is?
>> It's the law of identity.
>> What specific law of identity is it? Cuz
there's
There's Tell me what the law of identity
is.
There's categories within the law of
identity.
>> Would you like
>> does Leibniz's law say?
>> Wait. Do you Do you want me to teach you
what the law of identity is? Is that
what you're asking me?
>> I know. I want you to I want This is
what we're going to do. Cuz it shows It
seems like you don't know anything about
anything. Please don't tell me you don't
know anything about anything. You don't
even
>> know that relative identity was
connected to Peter Geach.
>> Leibniz's Cuz you didn't give me
Leibniz's law. What is that?
>> You don't even understand
>> Saying I don't understand doesn't mean
anything.
>> Hold on. Hold on, Avery. You didn't even
know that relative identity was
associated with Peter Geach.
>> I I That had nothing to do with the
argument.
That has nothing to do with the
argument. My position is relative
identity. What is your argument against
my position?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So my You said Leibniz's
law.
>> Okay. So what is Leibniz's law of
identity? What is it?
>> Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
>> what
Okay, what category
>> Are you okay? Do you understand?
>> of the law of identity
>> believe that the father is the son? Do
you believe that the father is the son?
>> So okay, let let me let me
>> father is the son?
>> No, I don't. So let me help you
>> believe in the father is the son.
>> help you out. This is this is your
blunder.
>> the son cuz you don't even know what
Leibniz's law is.
>> father begat himself.
>> Leibniz's law
>> begat himself. He says
>> He says
>> begat himself?
>> that his law of identity is called
absolute identity. Means that you have
to be absolutely identical in every way
and every sense.
>> Exactly you're right.
>> And guess what? There are philosophers
who do like Peter Geach and others who
do not hold to absolute identity. And so
we can keep going with examples. So
absolute identity is not There are
philosophers
that dispute
>> Wait, hold on. Avery, let me under Let
me teach you this. Let me teach you
this. Allow me to respond.
>> Leibniz's law of identity Absolute
identity is a necessity.
>> Let me Let me respond to you. Okay, and
let me teach you because this is
something Go ahead.
>> teach us what Leibniz's law is
necessary. Avery, have some respect
because listen, I've done six degrees,
yeah? Six degrees of 15 years
>> I'm trying to I'm trying to I'm trying
to respect you
>> Listen, don't interrupt me when I'm
talking.
You got degrees asking me questions
later. Ask me trivial questions. Don't
ask me whatever questions.
>> Ask me a trivial question now.
You didn't even know what Leibniz's law
was.
>> Hold on. Let me finish. This is an
education and it's a free one. Okay, so
just have some respect. Okay, and I'll
teach you about all these things later.
>> know what Leibniz's law was.
>> What do you mean? I've written a whole
chapter on Leibniz in my PhD.
>> So then tell us what does it state? What
is his law?
>> I've read Give me one book that Leibniz
wrote. One book.
>> There's another
>> No, give me one book THAT LEIBNIZ WROTE.
GUYS, WE'RE GOING TO
How many times do I have to tell you
that he wrote
Give me one book that Leibniz wrote.
>> Leibniz's law
>> exactly is if I was wrong.
Give me one book that Leibniz wrote.
>> Stop with the deflection.
>> One book.
>> The Muslim shuffle doesn't work. It
doesn't work.
>> it.
>> just be quiet.
>> You don't know what you're talking
about. What Leibniz's law is
>> anything that he wrote. I've written
CHAPTERS
>> SO TELL US. Tell us what his law is.
>> Be quiet. Shut up. Yeah.
Honestly, please. Leibniz's law is
equivalent to the law of identity. We've
already discussed
What are you doing, man? What are you
doing? Are you dumb?
>> Hey, look. I love how my food talks back
to me, ladies and gentlemen.
I love it. I'm enjoying it.
>> You've run away now from the from the
discussion, haven't you?
>> What do you mean? You're the only one
>> Is the father God?
Is the father God?
>> I already answered this. Can you tell us
what Leibniz's law is?
>> Are you Do you want Do I need to repeat
myself for the fourth time? You don't
even know who Leibniz is.
>> You want to get your thoughts together?
>> even know who Leibniz is. Who's Leibniz?
What did he invent?
>> Look Look at all
>> What's his first name?
>> Hey, I don't know his first name. Make
sure we count
>> What's his first name? How many times
has this dude deflected?
>> What's his first name?
>> What is Leibniz's law, Muhammad Hijab?
You brought it up.
>> What is his first name?
>> What is Leibniz's law?
>> I've already explained to you it's the
law of identity. Are you Are you
>> No. That's a It's a category within the
law of identity.
What specifically is Leibniz's law?
>> It's It's the law of identity. It's the
same as the law of identity. That's why
they call it Leibniz's law. The law of
identity is Leibniz's law.
>> I'll tell you what he says.
>> because you don't know what you're
talking about. You don't even know who
Leibniz is.
>> you?
>> You don't even know where he was from.
You don't even know what books he wrote.
You don't even know what his first name
was. You don't know anything about him.
You don't know anything about him.
>> I'll tell you and you
>> I've actually read all of his books.
>> By the way, I'll I'll teach you. You
tell me if I'm incorrect.
>> except for the the calculus one.
>> I'll tell you if I'm incorrect.
>> Don't be quiet. Don't talk about Leibniz
with me. Yeah?
>> It's my law.
>> You're not in a position to speak about
Leibniz. You're not for Leibniz.
>> Look. I'll tell you what his law is.
>> You tell me You tell me anything. You're
not in a position to do so.
>> Now the question is this.
>> Is the father God?
>> Leibniz's law is is that something is
identical if and only if they are
identical they share all the the
properties. They are identical in all of
their properties. Is that correct?
>> You're reading the over AI overview,
right? Okay, I'm looking at you. My
friend is telling me. All of Okay,
no problem.
>> Is that correct or not?
>> So so so so so so so good good. Do you
do you accept
Is that correct? Do you accept or not?
>> Is that correct?
>> Yes. Yes. Yes.
>> I had to teach you on what Leibniz's law
was. Thank you.
>> what are you stupid guy, man? Are you
all right? Are you all right?
>> So now dealing with Leibniz's law.
>> Okay.
>> hold to Leibniz's law.
>> Father God from Leibniz's law
>> Other philosophers
Leibniz's law.
>> Father God from a Leibniz's law identity
perspective.
>> Leibniz's law identity I don't hold to
that. I don't hold to Leibniz's law.
>> Ah, so you have to reject it, do you?
>> Yes. I don't hold to his law.
>> So you have to reject Leibniz's law, do
you?
>> You don't know what You don't know what
to do.
>> You accept
What are you laughing at? What are you
LAUGHING AT?
>> I'M I'M HAVING A You don't know where to
go from here.
>> This is trip was destroyed.
>> No, hold on. Hold on.
>> Okay, you're you're you're you're
putting in a relative identity
framework. What you don't understand is
the following. What you don't understand
is order in order for you to put forward
a relative identity framework, you have
to reject Leibniz's law. Leibniz's law
or the law of identity is in fact one of
the three major pillars of propositional
logic. You have three pillars of
propositional logic. One of them is the
law of identity. The other one is law of
non-contradiction, and the third one is
what? The law of excluded middle. These
are the three principle of propositional
logic. These are the pillars of it. Now,
in order for you to make your case, what
you're essentially admitting is the
following. That in order for me to make
a case for Jesus being God and in one
sense and Father being God in another
sense and Holy Spirit being God in
another sense, I have to reject one of
the pillars of propositional logic.
Propositional logic is the most
foundational and accepted logic in the
world for the last five 3,000 years
4,000 years. So you have to Do you
accept that in order for you to try and
justify a version of the Trinity, which
is Peter Geach's one, which is
repudiated by Christians himself, that
you have to accept a framework which
rejects one of the pillars of
propositional logic, yes or no?
>> No. So, can you demonstrate
>> No, no, no, no, but you just said you
reject Leibniz's
>> really quick. So, I'll let you talk.
>> So, you don't hold to it.
>> I let you
>> You said you don't hold to it.
>> talk for a very long
>> just said. You said you don't hold to
Leibniz's
>> for a very, very long time. So,
>> said you don't hold to Leibniz's
>> Muhammad hijab.
>> So, God logic doesn't believe in logic.
>> holds the law of identity.
>> You don't believe in logic. You don't
believe in logic.
>> No, no, that's not how you
>> You don't believe in logic. You don't
believe in logic. So, propositional
logic, you don't believe in it, do you?
>> You can't even
>> In order for you, in order for you to
justify the Trinity, you have to reject
Leibniz's
>> loud. Let me beat my chest instead of
have a discussion. So, relax.
>> I'm being honest.
>> I appreciate it.
>> Respond.
>> I don't have to hold to your view
>> Leibniz's, yes or no?
>> of of Leibniz's law in order to hold to
the law of identity. The law of identity
works with relative identity. I'm not
rejecting the law of identity.
>> That doesn't That's not
>> So, you can be identical in one sense
while having distinctions in another.
>> No, no, that's not how you That's even
That's how even how Peter Geach That's
not how he articulates it. He says
there's a sortal, and then he says that
the sortal is is represented by G, and
then you've got F, and then you've got
S, and you've got H, Father, Son, Holy
Spirit. And then he says that F is
relatively identical to G, and then S is
relatively identical to G, and the HS,
which is Holy Spirit, is relatively
identical to G. He doesn't say what
you're saying. He in fact rejects the
law of identity, which is what you've
had to do. You have to reject a pillar
of logic, yet you call yourself God
logic. YOU ACTUALLY CALL YOURSELF GOD
LOGIC, BUT YOU HAVE TO REJECT logic in
order for you to make some sense of the
Trinity, don't you? Yes or no?
>> No.
I'm I'm sorry that the script didn't
work.
>> Of course.
>> I'm sorry.
>> That's false.
>> That's false. I'm sorry that the I'm
sorry the script didn't work.
What you
>> Wait one second. He's rejecting logic so
much. His recipe says reduce until
thick.
>> Thanks for adding nothing to the
conversation.
I don't want to I don't want us to talk
over each other.
>> Do you reject the law of identity or
not? Yes or no?
>> I don't. So Hijab
Can I please speak?
The script is dismantled, has been
intellectually molested, has been cooked
and chefed and stirred up.
>> I think the people CAN SEE.
>> ACCORDING
>> THE people can
>> that in order to affirm my
identity that Leibniz's law is the same,
absolute identity is necessary.
So since we're going to spin a
20-hour clock
Can you demonstrate that Leibniz's law
necessitates absolute identity? Cuz
that's what you're saying. You're saying
that absolute identity
You can still affirm the law of identity
while being relatively the same. While
having the same
No, no, no,
notice how they're talking over me
still. Hijab, please.
Notice I let him speak, guys, and he has
to interrupt me and talk over me. This
shows the weakness in your position,
Hijab. Let me speak, bro.
>> I'll I you 20 seconds.
>> Not 20 seconds. Just let me say my
piece.
>> Okay, go on. Say your piece. Say your
piece. Say it.
>> Good lord, thank you. So, here's an
example.
If So, the Titanic, right? The Titanic,
before it got shipped off, it's in
perfect
condition, no scratches, no bangs, you
know, it's all good to go.
>> He's reading.
>> Gets shipped off, crashes into the
glacier, sinks, gets ripped up.
>> This my question.
This my question, Hajjaj.
Is the Titanic
that left the shore
absolutely identical in every way to the
Titanic that crashed into the glacier
and is sunk sunken? Is it absolutely
identical in every way?
>> I wasn't hearing what you were saying.
>> Just say this one more time.
>> Look, I don't even know what you're
talking about.
>> are.
>> You don't I don't even know what you're
talking about.
>> Yeah, you are.
>> Go back. Stop reading ChatGPT.
>> He's reading.
>> ChatGPT.
>> He's not reading.
>> This is the new generation, bro.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. Some people dumb.
>> I care about them.
>> I agree.
>> They don't know where to go.
>> The only Titanic is your
argument for sinking, brother. That's
the only thing that's sinking is your
argument. I don't even see your
arguments. Listen,
>> OKAY, I KNOW
>> YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE NOT UP THERE yet to
where you can understand the argument,
where you can hear the argument. Answer
the question.
>> What's the What is the question?
>> Is the Titanic that left the shore
absolutely
>> I don't know. Ask again. Is the Titanic
though?
>> Is the Titanic
that left the shore
absolute clown.
Is the Titanic that left the shore
absolutely identical in every single way
to the Titanic that crashed and sunk?
>> What?
What?
Surprise.
>> The Titanic that left the the shore the
same as the one that sunk?
>> They are absolutely identical in every
way.
>> Probably not, BECAUSE IT'S BEEN
>> BUT IT'S STILL THE TITANIC. SO, YOU just
affirmed
>> That the That is the worst That is the
worst thing I've ever heard. That is the
worst worst thing I have ever heard.
That is the worst thing I have ever
heard. That is the worst thing I have
ever heard. That is the worst thing I
have ever heard. That is the worst thing
I have ever heard. That is the worst
>> Okay, is is the Titanic the same Titanic
that sunk?
>> What are you talking about? Is it the
same ship?
>> So, what's the analogy here?
>> Is it the same ship?
>> What's the What's the analogy here?
What's the analogy?
>> Is the Titanic that left the shore the
same ship that sunk?
Make your point.
>> I'll ask it again.
>> No, no, make your point.
>> No, no, you're going to answer. You're
going to answer.
>> No, it's not the same one. It's a
different one. It's a different one.
>> Is the Titanic that left the shore
>> What does it mean? What does it
>> Is it the same ship that sunk?
>> What are you talking about, man? Okay,
no, it's not. No, you're right. You're
So, what does it mean? What does it
mean? What does it mean? What does it
mean?
>> Is I'll ask it again. I'll ask it again.
Cuz you just confirmed identity without
absolute identity.
You just confirmed identity without
absolute identity. I'll ask it again.
So, is the Titanic that left the shore
>> No, no, explain it to me how it goes to
the
Father, Son, Holy Spirit, please.
>> No, no, no. No, you're going to answer
this. I want you cuz I want I I I
>> No, no, I'm done. It's the same. It's
different. Some things are different
about it. No problem. Yeah, no problem.
>> Titanic that left the shore the same
ship?
What?
>> Yeah, I don't
Okay, what do you want me to say? I
don't know how he wants me to answer
this.
>> Hey, with all those degrees, man.
You're not You're not
You're not qualified for this level of
of of of, you know,
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
Avery.
>> You're not You're not ready, man.
>> Wait one second. One second. Let me
clear it up.
>> You're not ready. You just confirmed
identity, ladies and gentlemen. You just
confirmed identity. You're saying the
Titanic
>> I'm sorry, brother. I'm sorry. Let me
just land this and then I'll let you
speak, okay?
>> It's not the same one. That sunk.
>> Brother, I don't I don't want to speak
over you. I'm I want to hear what you're
saying. Just let me land what I'm
saying, okay? I'm landing what I'm
saying. And I And I promise I'll sit
quiet and I'll listen to you.
>> So, Muhammad Ali Jaber, you just
affirmed identity
disregarding absolute identity.
That's why you're
Uh go go ahead the person who's
>> through his divine identity. So from one
aspect he's God and from another aspect
he's not. Is that what you're trying to
say?
>> No.
>> So what what what are you trying to say?
What are you trying to say?
>> What are you trying to say? Make your
point, man.
No one understands you, man.
No one understands you.
>> So so the Father, Son, and Holy Spirit
are identical in essence while being
distinct in personhood or hypostasis.
>> Huh? Okay, okay, no problem. They're
distinct in hypostasis and in person.
Okay, no problem.
If they're distinct in person, do they
have separate centers of consciousness
or not?
>> I already answered this question. I'll
answer it again. They have the same
center of consciousness. They have the
same mind. Same will. Because let me
Tell me what's different. Yeah, tell me
what's different about it.
Oh, what's different about the persons?
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Sure. One So the Father begets the Son.
The Father is unbegotten. The Father is
unbegotten. The Son is begotten from the
Father and the Spirit proceeds from the
Father.
>> Oh, I see.
So no, great. I want I want let me learn
a bit more about the Trinity because I
want to know
>> You're learning a lot today.
>> No, no, I need to learn more about the
Trinity so
>> I'm here all day, man.
>> I'm here to teach me.
>> I'm here to serve.
>> Hold on, let me just ask you the
question so you can teach me about the
Trinity, please. Yeah, I want to know
cuz everybody wants to
>> What's your question?
>> All the Muslims want to
>> My question
boy is the following, okay?
Boy, the question is the following.
If it's true if it's true
that the Father
begets the Son, okay? You said that,
right?
>> Yeah, I did.
>> Does that mean that the Son is
generated?
>> Yes, he is generated eternally from the
Father.
>> Okay, beautiful. So if he's generated,
that means he's caused, right?
>> Uh yes, no. So when we're saying
Let me
>> He was Yeah, no, huh? What is it?
>> He's generated.
>> Let me let me explain. Let me explain.
>> I don't know.
>> Got you. So, when we say that the Son is
begotten or generated or caused by the
Father, this is not something that
happens in time, but this is eternal
generation, an eternal begotten.
>> Is he being perpetually caused? Is
>> He's He's eternally generated.
>> Aha. So, generated means he's
perpetually caused, is he?
>> Sure.
>> What?
>> So, caused.
>> Okay, so he's a contingent existent.
He's not a necessary existent. He's
contingent. He's a dependent being, is
he? Is your God dependent?
>> No, he's not dependent.
Let me Let me answer this now. He's not
a dependent being. To be To be a
dependent being means that you are
dependent or contingent on another being
outside of yourself. The Son shares the
same essence is the same being as the
Father. And so, therefore, the Father
eternally causing or generating the Son
is not
a demonstration that he's actually a
because his essence isn't sourced in any
other essence.
>> But you just said that he's he You just
said he's generated by the Father.
That's what you just said. He's caused
by
>> Yes, that's He shares the same essence
as the Father. This is the difference
between hypostatic properties and
properties. Being a dependent being
means that your essential properties are
contingent on another being.
>> All right.
>> Learn the categories of doubt. Remember,
>> Okay,
so now you admit You admit that he's
generated by the Father.
>> Eternally, yes.
>> Oh, he Eternally, that makes it even
worse because he's caused being caused
and caused and caused and caused and
caused and caused and caused. He's so
dependent that he needs to be caused
over and over again.
Is that what you told me?
>> Say that again, sorry.
>> Can you be caused and uncaused at the
same time?
>> Depends Yeah, it depends on what you
mean. So, you can be YOU CAN BE
>> NOW YOU'RE GOING STRAIGHT INTO THE
NON-CONTRADICTION. Now you've taken
non-contradiction
>> Yo, the manifestation IS INSANE.
>> NOW IT'S NON-CONTRADICTION, BOY.
>> THIS IS WHY
>> HOW DARE YOU TALK ABOUT ISLAM, BOY?
>> THIS IS THIS IS WHY
>> ISLAM, BOY?
>> THIS GOD IS UNCAUSED
>> YOU'VE BEEN CAUGHT OUT NOW, HAVEN'T YOU,
BOY? CAUSED AND UNCAUSED AT THE SAME
TIME NOW, HAVEN'T YOU, BOY?
>> YOU HAVE TO GET TO KNOW ONE OF THE FACES
OF DAWAH.
>> OH, you're done now, boy, aren't you?
>> in one WAY
AND UNCAUSED IN
ANOTHER
>> REPENT FOR YOUR WAYS. LEAVE CHRISTIANITY
immediately now. YOU'VE BEEN CAUGHT OUT.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO LET ME REPLY?
>> YOU'VE BEEN CAUGHT OUT NOW, HAVEN'T YOU,
BOY? HE'S CAUSED AND UNCAUSED
AT THE SAME TIME, IS IT?
>> NONE OF THIS WORKS, BRUV.
>> Caused and uncaused at the same time, IS
IT? IT'S A CONTRAVENTION
of non-contradiction or not, boy? Is it
a Is it a contravention of
non-contradiction or not, boy?
>> You've been trying to jump out the
pocket.
>> Is it a contravention of
non-contradiction or not, boy?
>> All right. Can
>> Is it a contravention of
non-contradiction or not, boy?
>> Can I CAN I ANSWER?
>> OH,
HE'S CAUSED AND UNCAUSED, is he? Is he
caused and uncaused?
>> Can I answer? Thank you. So, now I'm
about to answer your question.
So, hijab, this is you not understanding
categories. To For something to be a
contradiction, it has to be the opposite
in the same way, in the same sense. So,
when I say Jesus is uncaused and caused
at the same time, I'm not saying that
he's uncaused in the same sense that
he's caused. So, for example,
>> Another example.
>> him being caused by the Father, excuse
me. Him being caused or eternally
generated by the Father is a hypostatic
quality. It's a hypostatic property. No,
a relation that he has with the Father.
>> Sure. Sure. Let me ask you this.
>> He's not saying Excuse me. Excuse me. He
is not essentially caused.
Excuse me.
>> Can a necessary being be caused in any
way?
>> Excuse me.
>> Can a necessary being be caused in any
way?
>> Allow me to finish.
>> Can a necessary being be caused in any
way?
>> talks to me, but not
>> being be caused in any way, boy?
Can a necessary being be caused in any
way? Can an independent being be caused
in any way? Can an uncaused being be
caused in any way? boy?
Can a uncaused being be caused in any
way, boy?
>> to jump out the pot.
STOP TRYING TO JUMP OUT.
>> AND THIS IS WHAT THE Quran says.
Subhanallah. This is what the
>> This is what the Quran says.
You talked about the people who are
deceived and have disease in their
hearts.
>> He does not beget.
What I'm yakun lahu kufwan ahad. He does
not beget. Why? Because he's as-Samad.
>> Are you Are you going to continue in
your only your nervousness?
>> as-Samad. He's al-Ahad. He's al-Fard.
He's as-Samad.
>> Are you going to allow your nervousness
and your
>> lam yalid
>> fear to overcome you?
Be quiet for a second.
>> This is what's going to happen this
entire live stream tonight.
>> this.
Hey.
>> Now now the live stream, ladies and
gentlemen, has degraded because Muhammad
Hijab can't allow a discourse, a
dialogue.
>> Avery.
>> Allow me Allow me to finish what I was
saying without your interruption.
>> Avery. Avery.
>> Allow me to finish what I was saying
without
your interruption.
>> Avery. Avery.
>> So, I'm just going to continue.
So, the correct terminology
logical understanding of the properties.
>> Listen.
>> Jesus is not caused. He's sent because
he's eternally derived from the Father,
which is not derived from anything else.
>> Okay. Sure.
>> However, he
is caused hypostatically, eternally
generated. Meaning it doesn't happen in
time because that's his relation with
the Father.
>> I see.
>> So, it's not a contradiction because his
causation is in the sense of his
hypostatic relation with the Father
while he's essentially not caused by any
other being.
>> I'm hoping that you can respond to what
I'm saying.
>> in any sense. Can a necessary being be
caused in any sense?
>> Yes, hypostatically.
>> Then you're you're out of order. You're
out of order because you're out of order
and you don't know what you're talking
about.
>> A necessary being cannot be caused in
any sense with the consensus of
logicians regardless of the Father.
>> You're absolutely out of order.
You're absolutely out of order for you
to say, yeah, that is is is ridiculous.
So, your God is dependent, is he? In
that sense.
>> Refuted me.
>> No, again, to be dependent
To be dependent is to rely on a being
outside of yourself.
>> you. The Quran
>> showed me that my God is is is a
dependent.
>> refutes you by telling you clearly, the
Quran says, "Qul hu Allahu Ahad." Say
he's Allah one and only.
"Allahu Samad." He is the independent.
"Lam yalid walam yulad." He begets not
nor is he begotten. "Walam yakun lahu
kufuwan ahad." And there's nothing like
him. Why is Allah telling us that he's
independent and then telling us he does
not beget nor is he begotten? Because
it's clear that people like you
unfortunately believe it's possible to
be independent and dependent at the same
time. Allah is telling us, and this is
in line with classical logic, which
you've already rejected today, that it's
impossible to be independent and
dependent at the same time in any
respect, in even 1% respect. You cannot
be a necessary or independent being in
any respect, in any respect, and then
have an 1% dependency. You can't have 1%
dependency. You cannot have hypostatic
dependency. You cannot have essential
dependency. You cannot have
attributional dependency. You cannot
have any level ontological dependency.
And if you believe that you can, then
you are putting two things together
which contradict.
>> Is Allah
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, because
you're a fool. You're an idiot. And
you've misrepresented Peter Geach. He
doesn't believe what you just said.
>> Is Allah dependent on his attributes,
yes or no?
>> With the with the predicative view,
social trinitarianism, and uh what do
you call it? Latin trinitarianism.
>> I gave you monarchial trinitarianism.
>> You don't know philosophy. You don't
know what you're talking about.
You don't know what you're saying.
depths. You're completely out of your
depths. You don't know what you're
saying. You can drink, you can put
whatever hat and costume you want. You
have been
entirely decimated today. It's been
destruction upon destruction upon
destruction.
I want any any Christian that's watching
this today
Let me tell you this Christians, if
you're watching this and you just
watched this
and you just heard this presentation
about the Trinity and you still are
Christian, wallahi you are fooling
yourselves and you should be ashamed.
>> You are absolutely embarrassed.
>> There's no way you believe in that.
>> You don't believe in a God that's
dependent. You don't believe in a
>> You are absolutely embarrassed.
>> You don't believe in the generated God.
You don't believe in any of that stuff.
You believe in the one God that created
the heavens and the earth. That's what
we Muslims call you to. We call you to
the one God who created
>> Yes, the Father, Son, and Holy Spirit.
The one God who created the heavens and
the earth.
>> say about that.
>> the God of all creation and all that
stuff.
>> and on on the central level he's one.
That is an insufficient,
dissatisfactory, otherwise incomplete
answer.
>> There ain't no others. There ain't
>> It's impossible to reconcile. And if you
then you're either ignorant
you lost your mind.
You know Islam is true. You know there's
only one God worthy of worship. You know
there's only one God that doesn't beget
nor is he begotten. YOU KNOW THAT THE
FATHER can't
>> Allah is dependent.
>> You know that the Father can't
be God.
>> In order for him to have a son
>> and you know that the Holy Spirit can't
This is their strongest argument against
It crumbled. If this
it succeeded. We finished you.
Any last words before we go?
>> Yeah. Allah dependent on the man in
order to have a son. He's dependent.
He's dependent on Allah.
>> Let's bring out our friend. You can
speak to him, please.
>> He just refuted Allah.
>> Well, well, well.
>> Well, look who it is.
>> Shake life
>> Let me give you to talk to each other,
please.
>> Let me
>> Why why why are you substituting
>> Can I can I
can I speak?
>> No, you cannot speak.
>> I can't speak.
>> No, where you going?
>> Can I
>> ran away to bring up the puppy?
>> Hello, can I speak?
>> You ran away to bring up the pup?
>> Hello, can I
>> I thought I was talking to the champ.
>> Logic, can I speak?
>> THIS BOY NEED HELP.
>> WHAT'S WRONG, MAN?
>> Bro brought the rookie up.
I'm not I don't deal with rookies, man.
You've already dealt with. I'm I'm
talking to the champ.
>> Can I speak?
>> No, you cannot speak.
>> Why you
>> You you don't have a voice here.
>> Why are you
>> You don't have a voice here.
>> You don't want to speak to me?
>> Oh, looks like Muhammad Hijab ran. All
right, guys. So, looks like Hijab proved
that the trinity is not biblical. He
proved that he has absolutely no no
argument against the trinity.
I want to say thanks for coming, Hijab.
>> He's running. Look.
>> I apologize to my friend a little bit
there. I don't talk to rookies.
>> My friend I don't be scared of him. He
don't be scared of him. Why you scared?
>> I'll be a better.
>> Why you scared of him?
>> I JUST I JUST DESTROYED THE CHAMP.
>> DON'T BE no bro.
>> I just destroyed the champ.
Why would I talk TO THE PUP?
>> MY FRIEND wants to talk to you.
My friend wants to talk to you, man.
>> Hey, hey, man. Get get happy.
>> My friend wants to talk TO YOU.
>> HE'S RUNNING. WHY IS HE
>> I I won't talk to you again until you
get
>> Don't run away.
>> Hey, y'all. Peace, man. Hey hey, Hijab.
Thanks for having me, though, man.
>> He's running. He's running.
Let him run.
He doesn't want to talk.
>> You know what it is, uh, Orthodox? Sorry
to say. He doesn't want to He doesn't
want to admit this. But, you know, Avery
is a little bit like a prostitute, okay?
He's a little bit like a prostitute. You
know why?
>> Yeah.
>> Because every one of us has a turn on
this guy.
He's